Boom,
and we're alive.
Joshua,
how are you?
I'm good,
Joe,
how are you dude,
your story?
Well,
we were talking before this.
All right.
Because,
uh,
I had seen online that you,
had gotten fired for this whole Donald Sterling comment thing and then you had
said to me,
you took some heat for the Donald Sterling thing too,
but not really.
I didn't.
There's,
there's no,
there's only the only real heat is you get in trouble.
Like you lose your,
you lose a job.
You actually got fired for saying something that's entirely reasonable.
And I'm going to paraphrase what you said,
but I believe what you said was he has every right to be an old bigot in the
privacy of his home and that he's a victim because this fucking floozy that he
was hanging around with had recorded him and then leaked the audio.
Right.
Which is totally,
completely reasonable.
You called him an old bigot.
You didn't in any way support him.
I said he was a bigot in my own,
my own statement.
Even the statement that was isolated.
Yeah.
Thank you for picking up on that.
But this idea that in the privacy of your own home that your words should be,
they should be gone over with a fine tooth comb by the entire world and then
that's not some horrendous invasion of privacy.
Like that's fucked man.
To me,
that invasion of privacy is a way more egregious error than someone being a
shithead it as on time.
Right.
And even what he said,
the reality of what he said,
he said,
and he never used a racial slur.
I mean calm a bigot if you will.
But what he said was,
I don't want to his girlfriend.
I don't want you taking pictures with these black guys.
I don't care if you fuck them.
Right.
But I don't want you taking pictures with them.
Like I don't care if you fuck them is a huge part of his statement.
I would not say that's a bigot.
I mean,
look,
so worst case,
right?
We're or best case if,
if w depending on what your perspective is,
social justice warrior or or,
or whatever.
But yeah,
best case scenario,
worst case scenario,
he's a bigot.
Right.
But right.
Even that shouldn't affect me the way that it seemed to have been effecting
everybody.
Right.
And the way that the media was hyping it up and the media was,
was spinning it and totally not necessarily looking at the other kind of really
bad CD shit that was going on around that whole thing.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean,
I have to question what is the mistress,
his motives in that,
right.
Like all that's hearsay and I know that in the wake of all of that,
there was lots of finger pointing and he said,
she said going on and,
and lawsuits filed.
But I think that,
you know,
it's not hard to imagine that her motives weren't pure.
You know,
they weren't,
they weren't like,
it wasn't like she was some White Knight,
you know,
rushing into,
to,
to do some great social justice.
I think that at the end of the day,
she was really out to take this guy down or get something out of it.
Right.
Well,
didn't she say that she didn't release it?
I believe that was her statement.
Yeah.
I mean,
whoever,
whoever got ahold of it,
I don't know what her statement isn't at the end of the day,
Joe,
to me it's hearsay,
right?
That all of that shouldn't matter to me.
What matters to me is like,
and what I was trying to call attention to,
what I've always tried to call attention to is the way people kind of,
we have these weird priorities.
We,
we love to be,
have this endorphin drip.
We love to be angry,
we love to be a part of something big.
And then we don't necessarily take a step back and look at like the big picture
of what was happening,
what was going down and um,
and what could we be talking about instead of all of this stuff.
Right.
Well,
it's just infuriating to me that you can get fired for what I believe is an
incredibly innocuous statement.
I mean,
maybe this is coming from me,
maybe my,
my perception of the difference between working for a public company and,
and,
and having controversial opinions and you know,
me being a comedian,
a cage fighting commentator,
and so does it,
I have different standards.
I guess it's a different world.
Yeah.
I mean,
I can say something pretty fucked up and I'll,
I might get a call from the UFC and then I'm like,
wait,
what are you drunk?
You know,
like that,
that's,
they're like,
yeah,
pretty much I might say it then I'll say,
sorry,
I was fucked up and then it goes away.
But I,
you know,
I just can't believe that the standards are so low or that the,
the,
the outrage standards that it's like,
it requires such a minimal ripple on the seismic,
you know,
the seismograph that people will freak out to the point where you can lose your
fucking job for calling someone a bigot and saying,
this guy should have the right to do that in his home and be,
be a piece of shit.
I know,
I know what to expect from,
um,
from Westboro Baptist church.
Right.
I know what to expect from the KKK.
I don't agree with any of that shit.
And I,
I,
uh,
bore it,
I think that they're all scumbags,
but,
but I,
I kind of know what to expect from that.
And that shouldn't surprise me when,
when some headline comes out or when they do some weird stuff,
right.
Um,
a lot of people were saying,
you know,
well,
Donald Sterling,
he had this huge long history of being like racially weird and,
and,
and questionable.
So it's like,
well then why,
why you acting really surprised that this thing happened at all and why are you
supporting like a breach of privacy in that way?
Because that to me is a,
is a,
is a more sort of unalienable right.
Um,
to,
you know,
to privacy.
I completely and totally agree.
And I think that,
that this,
this idea that somehow or another,
you should be on your best behavior all the time.
You can't just say something.
If you're alone,
you want to say something completely disgusting.
You may or may not mean it.
You might be under the influence of alcohol or drugs,
but you're not giving public statements.
Right?
And so for those public statements or for it to get out like a public statement
and for people to absorb it like a pump and then analyze it and critique it and
criticize it and then get crazy about it.
I found it ridiculous.
And I think if the guy does have this long history of being racist,
I understand then,
then I understand why people were upset.
Like they look good.
We got him like here it is.
Right.
We caught them but what did they do with me?
But understand how you caught him.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean you caught him in a fucked up way that nobody should get caught that way.
I mean that's just not how the world is supposed to work in America in 2015 I
mean what,
what,
what does everybody upset about?
Everybody's upset about this Edward Snowden thing,
right?
Cause Edward Snowden found out that the NSA is secretly wire tapping every
fucking phone in the country and recording all your emails,
recording all your,
your voicemails and everybody got crazy.
Like that's outrageous.
Well that's no different.
This is all private stuff.
I mean this is very similar.
It's along the same lines,
the idea that you can be judged in him ultimately.
I mean guy got his fucking team got taken away,
hammered.
I mean it's insane.
It changed the course of his life.
And for someone like that to like he's a billionaire,
he's the money aspect is hardly anything for him.
Right.
To him it's his legacy.
The thing that mattered most to him,
completely trashed,
completely gone.
And again,
I,
it doesn't matter who he was and what other people thought of him.
And what matters again to me is just the way that,
and honestly I wasn't even that mad at the NBA because if you look at,
if you look at the position they were in,
they kind of had their hand forced and a lot of ways,
uh,
under this,
under this torrential downpour of like media and public discourse.
And so like,
in a way I almost like empathize with,
with them in the position that they were put in.
But,
but to me it's the way that we reacted to it and the way that we kind of were
okay with it at a part of it.
And so I was trying to be the,
the one voice of reason at the time,
swimming,
swimming against the stream to try to bring some,
some,
you know,
common sense of the conversation,
which is like this guy,
he's not this weird monster dude.
You know,
he's not like this,
this,
you know,
crazy guy who's wreaking havoc and,
and blowing up the cities and towns.
Like he's an old guy who grew up in an era where very different than ours and he
might have some weird shit floating around in his head and maybe,
maybe all of that was true.
But at the end of the day,
what still is not right is what's happening to him right now.
And you made this one tweet,
which again,
I think it's fairly innocuous.
I actually know completely innocuous,
totally justified.
The first tweet the company you were working for makes in response to it.
They call you,
they're former community leader.
Was that how you found out you were fired?
Practically.
Um,
so I'll,
I can run it through the time table list if you want it.
So,
so the,
the beginning of the day,
what company was it again?
Oh,
well,
the company that I work for is called Turtle Rock Studios.
A bunch of really talented artists who are making it an incredibly ambitious
game called evolve.
Um,
and so the game was,
the game is and was and still is really awesome.
Um,
but the,
the,
the company,
you know,
game development,
we work in a slightly different clock than most of corporate America.
We've worked,
we'd go in at like 10:00 AM and we leave at like 7:00 PM,
because we're usually up until really late in the late in the evening.
So I really don't even wake up until nine o'clock
every day,
most days.
So that day I woke up and my phone was kind of buzzing and blowing up.
Um,
uh,
one of my,
one of my really close friends and colleagues at the time texted me and he was
like,
Hey,
by the way,
you know the stuff you tweeted about the other day,
like some news outlet picked up on it,
some small thing and old sure group,
exactly who we wanted to capitalize on that,
on that,
that sensational headline.
And so he,
he was just giving me a heads up and I was like,
Oh yeah,
you know,
thanks.
Whatever.
Um,
it to me at the,
at the time I was like,
whatever,
like I know what the group that,
I don't want to name the site,
but,
but I know what they're about.
They do this all the time.
So I was like,
whatever.
Um,
and then,
so,
uh,
maybe I jumped in the shower and I get out and I've got texts from like our GM
at our,
at our studio,
like,
you need to go radio dark on all social media period.
And I was like,
what?
I was like,
And so I texted him back and I'm like,
is this in relation to the article?
The one article that no one else picked up on and that like,
um,
you know,
half the comments were like,
that dude,
that's totally not what Josh was saying.
And the other half were kind of reacting sensationally to it,
but like the other half even on the comments and Erica were like,
you're taking them out of context.
And that was the entire extent of the controversy circling me at the time.
Um,
and then 45 minutes later I still have,
you know,
left my apartment to go into the studio yet 45 minutes later my email stops
working and I'm like,
oh,
like I'm not dumb.
That's stupid.
I'm like,
they literally just shut off my email.
Um,
and then so I tried calling him and he didn't take my call and then an hour
later he's like,
yeah,
we should,
we should probably meet it like to Starbucks around the corner.
And I was like,
what?
Like you don't even want me to come into the office and talk about this.
Like you don't want to hear my side of it.
You don't want to see what's what,
like it's just done.
And then they issued the statement that they made,
which was like the literally putting the match to the kerosene.
So maybe there was some kerosene,
maybe there was some like potential for outrage and then when they fired me,
it turned into this huge thing in the gaming industry around like,
was that right?
Was that wrong?
So like the vast majority of people who have never even heard about that or even
would've cared that I tweeted that.
Um,
kind of like everybody heard about it,
um,
mainstream heard about it.
Like Mark Cuban started following me on Twitter.
Like if you were,
if they were afraid the NBA was going to get pissed at us for me for weighing in
and then,
you know,
they're kind of reaction to it and made it like 50 times worse.
Yeah.
I wish I was in on it when it happened cause I would've went crazy and no,
I would have tweeted,
and you know,
we would have talked about it on the podcast as it happened.
I,
I wasn't aware of it until after the fact,
but it,
to me,
it's smacks of this outrage culture that we're in now where people were just
waiting for the green light to be a cunt and that that's what it is.
It's,
it's not really that they're angry at this.
I don't believe it.
I think there's a great deal of fake outrage,
recreational outrage that we're experiencing in our culture right now.
And it's because people for the first time ever have a voice instantly to talk
about anything.
And that's what Twitter is.
That's what Facebook is.
You instantaneously can project your thoughts out to the world.
And people love doing it and they love being pissed off and they're most likely
pissed off because of their life.
They're most likely pissed off because of the relationship or their job or their
weight or you know,
whatever the fuck it is.
But they're just not balanced people.
And there's a lot of them and they're looking to hit that fucking gas pedal when
they see that green light because that greenlight was that Josh Hollins,
a pizza shit that fuck mother fucker.
He supported Donald Sterling dairy.
How dare you sending racism
in 2015 and here's the scary thing for me,
Joe,
is that these people,
I mean these people,
I don't want to like make people sound weird,
but they've,
oh they've always been here and they've only now had the microphone to talk
about this.
So we as a society,
society has to be better than the individual.
I'm saying what I'm trying to say is that these individuals who you know are
fueled by that they've always been around and now we as a society need to be
bigger than the individual and we need to look at that and understand we need to
identify what it is,
understand why it's wrong and the kind of damage and the kind of risk it
presents to free thinking,
free speech and even industry.
And then we need to,
you know,
change the way we're behaving very consciously,
very cognizantly with every,
with you know,
everything that we do to try to suppress those feelings.
Cause they're just natural tendencies.
Like if you,
if you try to boil it down to just the,
like the neuroscience of it,
these are just like emotional receptors in our brains.
It's,
it's what makes us tick.
It's the,
it's,
it's why these click baity articles like,
you know,
11 crazy wonders of the world revealed after you click this link.
It's why that that is so successful because those appeal to the emotional
centers of our brain instead of the cognitive centers of our brain and being too
kind,
they appeal to retards say,
well
that's what's going on.
What you're doing,
what you're doing with Twitter and with Facebook is empowering the whole world
to communicate.
And it's a beautiful thing.
It's,
it's amazing.
It was meant to be a beautiful thing.
And I as a social psychologist,
like I self prescribe myself to that.
I didn't go to school for this,
but I'm fascinated by it.
I learned,
I tried to learn everything I can about it.
And,
and in my position that I've been in,
I've,
my whole career in building and architecting communities and,
and the way people interact online and with on social media.
So I say this with like a certain amount of self loathing because I was kind of
part of the probability that empire up.
Now I look at back at it and I think there's problems with this and,
and it's,
it's unlocking a,
like a,
a toxicity that is running rapid across a bunch of different issues and,
and it leads to just hate and bile and venom and harassment and sure.
Now,
I honestly believe is a temporary step,
uh,
on,
on the way to more enlightened culture.
I really do believe this and I think that what we're experiencing now is people,
when you see someone write something like,
what was the name of this company that you work for again?
Turtle Rock,
Third Rock,
turtle rock studios.
You do not fire this man.
You know,
expect me to boycott your business.
You don't know who wrote that.
That guy could be shitting his pants as he wrote it.
He could be jerking off into fucking other people soup.
He could be,
you know,
driving on the highway with one foot on the gas and one hand on his cell phone
on the other hand,
on his dick.
You,
you don't know.
We don't know who these people are there words.
Anyone can type a sentence,
anyone can talk,
but you don't know who that person is.
Like what should I consider your opinion?
We all know idiots.
We all,
we've all run into idiots in our lives that if you went to them with an opinion,
you ask them a question about anything.
They're likely to give you some really fucking stupid answer.
And you wouldn't even consider it because you go,
oh well that's Mike.
Mike's a tool,
you know?
Of course he said that he's a fool.
And when you see Mike's words written down with a period and an exclamation
point and it looks all normal,
like it doesn't seem like it came from a fucking idiot.
We're used to talking to people.
I look at you,
I can tell you a reasonable intelligent guy.
We're having a wonderful conversation and your normal okay.
But if you're some fucking idiot,
and you were saying the same,
you know,
thing that these people that are outraged,
uh,
you know,
about your,
your tweet about Donald Sterling,
if you were an idiot and you were saying that,
I would immediately dismiss it.
I would say,
well,
this guy's an idiot.
This is real simple.
But en masse and,
and,
and in that wave and online and social media,
like that context,
you don't know and you don't know if this guy's an idiot or if he's a thought
leader or,
and so then all of those messages and all of those tweets and all of those
hashtags,
they add up and it's,
it,
we lose the context.
I mean,
we lose the forest through the trees.
We don't just do that.
It's also these people have an earned the ability to communicate.
They haven't earned it.
They've just found it.
Like,
I haven't earned it.
I just found it.
I mean,
I stumbled upon this ability through the Internet.
that's what's we've all done.
You haven't really earned it right.
At least you're consistent about it,
right.
Your,
your message is always fairly fairly coming from a very pragmatic place.
You,
you take a look at the guy,
one arbitrary guy who was,
who is typing some anger shit and his Twitter feed and you scroll back through
his history and the stuff that he was complaining about just the other day or
the last week.
It could be in stark contrast to whatever he happened to be anger about today.
Right?
Or coming from a completely different place of,
of morals and standards that he has.
Well,
that's one of the coolest things about Twitter's.
And when someone says something really stupid,
he go to their Twitter page and go,
oh,
look at this amazing river of retardation that's coming out of your fat head.
You know,
it's funny,
I,
I used to have a real problem with like,
I used to get baited easily into stupid arguments and just stupid spend hours
trying to change a guy.
And,
and uh,
and I started doing that,
right?
Where I'd click through and I read through it.
I'm just like,
it's,
this isn't worth it.
It's not worth my time.
It's almost never worth it.
But I think that these people have never had this ability to communicate before
and they don't think about it too much.
And I think that this power that human beings have today through social media,
it's amazing.
Like ultimately it's way better.
It's way better than not having it,
and it's an amazing time.
But this is how I like to put it in perspective to people.
If you're in a room with a hundred people,
what are the odds that one of those people is a total fucking moron?
It's about a hundred percent if you have a hundred people in a room,
well,
you'd have 99 amazing people.
As a comic,
you see this all the time.
It's the,
it's the one heckler.
It's the one of course,
holding in their room,
right?
And so you just expand that out to the whole world.
Expand that up to the entire Twitter and sound domain.
Well,
just the whole planet looking at the United States of America,
if it's one out of a hundred that means there's three point whatever,
five,
what is it?
350 million people in this country.
Yeah.
That's three and a half million retards.
Three and a half million million.
Slobbering shitheads just pounding on their keyboards.
Demanding action,
demanding.
You get fire demanding,
you get reprimanded,
demanding you apologize.
And over what?
Over the over their shitty fucking lives.
That's what it is.
But these what the real,
the real problem is is that companies like turtle rock are pussies and that
they,
they can't look at this rationally.
They can't look at this reasonably to human beings.
Just like,
why did you write that?
Oh,
I wrote it because,
you know,
I feel like the invasion of privacy thing is much more important than the fact
that this guy said something that was,
you know,
racially fucked up.
Okay,
good point.
I mean,
that could really at the end of it,
yeah,
but you're,
you're taking these opinions from all these other people,
people that are chime in and just because they're looking for that fucking green
light,
they're looking to hit that gas cause they're frustrated because they're stuck
in traffic all day because they're,
their body sucks because the,
the girlfriend has want to touch them.
Whatever the fuck reason it is context.
That's their life context.
But that's their shit.
Let them,
let them deal with it.
Right.
Don't bring repercussions than other people.
And again,
me,
you know,
I'm fine.
Whatever I'm doing just fine.
But the,
the,
the kind of damage that that did to people that I cared about who we're still at
the company,
right?
Like my friends,
they're my colleagues who,
because when that'll happen,
like it was,
it was just that,
right?
It was mostly people just yelling and angry at them for doing what they did to
me.
Right.
Well,
they should be that.
That makes sense.
And,
and,
and so that should be the repercussion for firing someone for free speech and,
and that,
and that wasn't,
that wasn't good though either.
Right?
Like,
that was still really bad too.
And that,
that wasn't to me,
that wasn't even any better,
right?
That,
no,
the way it's better is you take the person fire you and they should be fired and
they should be publicly flogged.
Take them out with rubber dicks.
Just smack them in the face like a hundred lashes.
It's just,
it's nonsense.
It's,
it's,
it's a fools endeavor to,
to try to please all the fucking idiots of the world and to
not look at that raw,
I don't know how anybody can look at what you said rationally and be outraged.
You'd have to be a real fucking piece of shit to get angry without enough to
think that you should lose your ability to make a living.
You should lose your job.
But that's what people love to do.
They love to get people fired.
I mean,
it's one of the more invasive aspects of social media,
the social justice warrior types that we'll try to get people fired from their
job and they will organize and attack and they're trying to get a result and
when they get a results like these turtle rock dummies who fired you,
they feel like they've claimed victory,
but there's no victory there.
You know,
you went on to get a better job.
They went on to get fucked over the whole thing turned into a big shit fest and
online it became this hot point of debate and I think ultimately they should
learn and everyone should,
everyone should learn.
That's the thing.
What I would want to do and what I keep doing it and I didn't,
it didn't stop at all.
By the way,
I love,
I'm okay with being the provocative guy,
right?
Provocation doesn't always have to be a negative word,
There's anytime you evoke an emotion,
it's because you're saying something distinct.
You're saying you're not being just sameness and muted and and an average and
completely agreeable.
I like being the guy who has like poignant thoughts,
who wants to share a different angle in a different perspective with as many
people as I can and just try to keep the conversation moving forward because
what you end up seeing and what people are trained into doing,
which which happened with with my whole thing is is they get trained and to and
to taking aside and then closing off the other side.
You see this a lot with you have any,
do you have any like Facebook friends that are like super like Wah Wah,
like some who either super religious or some who were super atheist and you
watch some of the arguments they get in and you watch the,
the aftermath of them.
Like I had a,
I like a die hard atheist friend of mine who who would always argue with,
with,
with Christians,
always argue with anybody who says like thank you know,
thank God for being here for me through this hard time.
And he would even go on that post and argue and debate with them.
Like,
he's kind of just,
that guy is that guy at the,
at the party.
And so what I noticed that he would keep doing is he'd get into these arguments
and then he would defriend all of the religious people.
And when I take a step back and I observe his behavior,
what he's doing is he's surrounding himself with more and more likeminded
people.
And he's removing any other discourse that like how do you don't evolve unless
you debate unless you have a conversation.
Right?
So he's just surrounding himself with more of these likeminded people who share
his ideas and then he's ranting inventing with those group of likeminded people
about how angering the other side makes them.
So now he's not even having a debate with the other side.
He's just having this circle jerk with his own,
with his own group of friends about,
about what they assumed the other side thinks and means and believes.
And so you take that with any issue or,
or,
um,
with any set of values that you have.
It's the same thing.
Anytime that you cut off ties with another person,
you can,
you could call that.
Well,
I just surround myself with people who make me happy,
but I call that almost like if that's the case,
then you've kind of forfeit the right to be mad at me for having a different
opinion because if you're not going to come and to the table and and understand
what my opinion is and and have an and have a conversation with me about where
I'm coming from,
then I mean you kind of lose the right to make up your mind about what I think
and believe.
That's a very good point.
It's a very good point.
As long as you look at it reasonably and as long as you look at it objectively
and saying,
how am I getting anything good out of this?
Like for example,
you arguing with these people online that you don't want to argue with you.
You go to their Twitter feed,
look at what they're saying to you and you go,
what am I doing?
Should I might getting involved with them?
I don't want to engage with this person because it's pointless to me.
Like in that sense like,
well no,
you don't need to let that person into your life.
And if you read some ridiculous inflammatory stupid shit that someone's writing,
you can make a a value choice.
You can make a choice.
Like you know what,
my time is very valuable and I just,
I'm going to defend this guy.
I don't want to be involved.
But there is something that's going on in this culture that I think is happening
because of this incredible new ability to communicate and form these groups of
likeminded people.
When you get this massive confirmation bias and these groups and because of that
they,
they reject outright any notion of debate upon these issues.
And this is a big problem right now in universities.
Yeah.
It's a huge problem where people don't want to be offended and they're trying to
create safe spaces and they're trying to create places where you,
you can't say things that they might think are offensive,
but you might think are totally reasonable.
Like your tweet,
like your tweet in a lot of universities with thought to be would be deemed
incredibly offensive.
Even though it's,
it's a legitimate subject of debate.
It's a legitimate subject of debate.
Like why,
why try to change us old fuck,
he's going to be dead in a month.
Like what do you give a shit?
Why are we wasting energy on this exact so many bigger issues that we face every
day that you can fall into a lot of war right now?
And yet we're worrying about Donald fucking sterling.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and anytime that you say that now,
like you run the risk of just Joe Rogan a racist is he don't care about race
relations in the United States.
And it's like that,
that's not the point.
But you don't run that risk.
That's not true.
You run that risk with idiots.
It's not a reasonable risk,
you know?
It shouldn't be.
It shouldn't be and it's not.
It's not,
and that's where your company fucked up because that's,
it's not a reasonable,
if you look at what you wrote,
what firing someone for that is not a reasonable reaction.
If you look at what you wrote,
being infuriated at you and wanting your job and wanting your head,
why don't you to pay in one you to publicly apologize.
That's not a reasonable reaction either.
This idea that everyone has to acquiesce,
that everyone has to bow down to the masses and then anytime there's anything
controversial,
you're best off just keeping your mouth shut.
You best off just not communicating and not projecting your thoughts for,
for for fear of other people disagreeing and then the hate and the anger
secure.
You're just,
what does that world look like?
Diluted down generation over generation.
Is that really the world you would want to be in South America?
I tell you that.
That's not my America.
Yeah,
it's a land of pussies.
It's ridiculous.
It's just,
you said the confirmation confirmation bias is probably the best way to put it.
It's all,
it's also,
it's also the,
no pun intended,
the black,
the way we look at it,
black and white,
we look at it like there's no,
there's no gray area with a lot of these people.
So it,
there's um,
in gaming and other biggest year and I was feminism and Gamergate and um,
and so the,
you know,
you,
you take a,
a feminist activist who sang some stuff.
And if you are too,
which by the way,
let's say I wholly support equal rights,
gender equality,
all to all forms of quality,
I think,
I think people should be deemed as who they are as people and what they're
saying and what they're bringing to the world doesn't matter about your age,
gender,
sexual orientation,
nothing.
So the,
the,
um,
but let's say that I'm talking to a feminist and she says something that I think
is just wrong.
I think it's a,
it's a bad opinion.
It's an opinion form based on a bias or it's a,
it's an invalid stat.
And I argue with her for one second.
I'm immediately a misogynist.
I'm immediately a sexist because I opposed one point of her platform and now
suddenly I'm the antibiotic again,
again only to idiots and only two people that aren't looking at things
objectively and only if people that are coming into it with a bias in the first
place.
But it's it just,
is it just idiots because let's say,
let's say you're that feminist,
right?
Let's see here that activist and let's say you're a really smart person and
you've done a lot of research and you're just,
you're so,
you're,
you're a smart person,
but you're so invested in your mission,
you're so invested in what you're fighting for that you forget just for one
minute,
for one minute,
you forget that there's another side to it that there's other perspectives.
Is that the way of looking at other ways of looking at an issue,
even just for one second and you say something and then a bunch of people
retweeted and then it looks bad for the guy.
You know,
in a way that person who's the smart person technically influenced a lot of that
like negative shit from it from happening that then transpired.
And so in a lot of ways it's like having a conversation with even the smart
people.
We think that they're leading activism and they're leading,
they're leading the charge on things.
You know,
it's trying to educate that tier of people who can be spoken to reasonably to
understand that like,
you know,
you need,
you need to be more open minded in the sec.
The second that you push someone away,
you're already,
you're already like,
uh,
like abandoning your cause.
Your costs should be bringing more people in the secondary,
you react to what someone else said and you push them away like that.
You're,
you're technical.
You know,
you're the one not technically you're,
you're the one doing the wrong thing.
Well,
the problem with this conversation right now is that it's kind of vague and
we're not talking about very specific statements that could be debated on their
merit.
W versus this idea of,
uh,
immediately using an ad hominem.
Like you're a massage NIST I,
that is the best way to shut down any sort of debate.
I immediately call you a racist,
sexist.
I mean that's,
that is the,
that's the feminism playbook.
The,
the dumb feminism playbook,
not the intelligent feminists that look at the reality of the
world and see qual inequality and want to correct that and don't hate men.
Like there was this woman that was doing something for Google ideas or I forget
what the exact thing was,
but she was arguing with people on Twitter.
And one of the things you said is,
I eat men for breakfast.
Like,
well,
why should that be?
Yeah,
you're a fucking ridiculous human.
What you eat every one of the opposite gender.
So are you in a,
at a war,
you were in a gender war.
It's like,
is this,
do you want to make,
create a quality for women?
Or do you actually want to make up for all the men who rejected you or shit on
your,
dumped you or broke your heart or or whatever or whatever it is.
What is it?
Is it,
you have picked a team and you're fighting for that team,
like the dolphins versus the 40 niners because that's what it seems like and
that is what it is.
It's Mac versus windows.
I mean it's,
it's fucking android versus iPhone.
People pick fucking teams.
They get crazy.
It Chicago versus New York.
Fuck Hill.
I'm from San Francisco.
It's the same goddamn thing.
And you decide,
you know,
I'm a feminism and feminism man fucking suck.
Yeah.
Well no,
men don't suck.
Men are humans,
you know,
and women don't suck either.
They're humans.
Individuals in each gender suck.
And the idea that you're going to be on team vagina and it doesn't have any
rotten players,
you're fucking crazy.
You're crazy.
You're instantly crazy.
If,
if any man tries to say that,
all men are amazing,
that guy's a fucking idiot.
Right?
Like what are you looking around?
Are you,
are you talking to people?
Have you looked at history?
Have you taken a poll recently of the opinions of these fucking guys with decks?
There's a lot of guys who are shithead,
shithead,
Donald Sterling's one of them.
And Michelle heads maybe.
I mean,
I don't know.
based on what you said,
especially in a quilt in issues of equality,
yes,
there's no,
No side should be losing one site doesn't have to when Niggas on the other side
having to lose like that shouldn't be on teams.
It should be the human race.
Right.
You know,
I,
there's big fans of a lot of women.
I think a lot of women have achieved some fucking incredible,
amazing thing.
And I think there's a lot of men that I think a disgusting,
right?
There's a lot of men I think are losers and they're annoying and they make
excuses for their failures and they,
it's never about them.
It's always about they got fucked over it.
Like,
oh,
they're fucking brutal and boring and tiresome.
And,
and they,
they are roadblocks.
The roadblocks for conversations.
They are blood clots for progress.
I mean there's a lot of people like that out there.
Well both genders.
And I think that,
you know,
this whole idea of feminism and you know,
one of the things that happened that I thought it was really hilarious,
um,
I don't remember what it was about,
but I retweeted something cause I retweet tweet things that are provocative with
Ar.
I don't agree with them.
I don't believe that a retweet should be an endorsement,
I think.
But it triggers thought it makes pants have a thought in their head for one
moment of the day.
So this woman who was a feminist called me an Mra.
So what's the fuck is that?
So I had to Google it.
It's a men's rights activist.
So I'm like,
hold on.
Are you really mocking me for supporting men's rights?
When you're a feminist,
like a youth,
you're mocking it.
You're openly mocking the idea of men's rights.
But meanwhile you're supporting female rights.
This is preposterous.
You're a crazy person.
Lost in this constant struggle.
And then I went to her Twitter page and checked her out.
Of course,
she's morbidly obese and she has pink hair,
so she's,
she's a mess.
Right.
But that,
that's the real cause of all this strife and anxiety and anger.
It has virtually nothing to do with the issue itself.
These are,
these issues become greenlights for some people,
for some people.
Yeah.
I completely agree.
In that particular case,
it was certainly true,
but I think that this,
this feminism in gaming thing,
like,
boy,
I don't,
I've,
I've looked at both sides of this,
this,
it's convoluted on both ends.
Yet the hate that these women who were involved in video game development have
gotten from men is fucking disgusting.
Of course.
I mean,
the harassment and then people say,
oh,
the death threats aren't even real.
Like,
what the fuck ever.
They still get them,
you know?
I mean,
if,
and,
and they're,
and they're not just,
it's not just,
I'm going to kill you.
It's so dark.
It's so toxic.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's way more violence being directed at them,
you know,
whether it's real or not,
but I didn't print that.
It is directed at the men that are supposedly the oppressors.
Right.
You know,
you're not seeing like a bunch of women saying we should get together and cut
all these guys' dicks off and stuffed them down their mouth and make them choke
to death on it.
But this,
this whole fucking battle like at the,
at the root of it all,
it should be a battle about what we should be developing.
Games should be about what is the best way to make a really quality game that
people are going to enjoy and what is the best way that all these people can
interact with each other.
It shouldn't be about like,
well we need 10 women because we have 10 men and the women should have an equal
say because I know the men shouldn't even have an equal say now your,
your,
your ideas should stand on their own merit.
I hate the idea of quotas it across most issues when you,
especially when you talking about like police having quotas for the number of,
of certain races they need to investigate.
That's wrong.
And at the same time on the other side with,
with this issue,
it's like,
yeah,
I hate the idea that you need to hire so many of these people just because,
right.
Just just to keep the balance equal.
It's a horse shit did and it's th there's,
there's some real clear,
um,
areas in life where,
you know,
it's a horseshit idea.
The NFL is one of them.
Okay.
If there was a quota in the NFL where the NFL needed a certain amount of women
to play as linebackers,
sure.
Do you know how fucked up football would be?
Right.
If you needed to have,
you know,
how many linebackers are there?
Three.
If you needed to have at least one woman,
we do,
you know,
fucking horrific and preposterous.
Those games would be,
everybody would just shoot threatened straight for the chick and run her over.
Right.
And then you'd be accused of sexism because you,
you keep giving that girl concussions,
but that it's,
she's not qualified for that position.
That position belongs to some square jawed fuckhead from Indiana who's been
taken steroids since he was a baby.
That's,
that's the guy you want for that job.
You want some 500 pound fucking gorilla,
it's going to stop people from crossing that space.
That's,
that's it.
that's in,
that's the clearest example of a quota.
And the same could be said creatively,
like the idea that you,
you want a certain amount of women or a certain amount of men and nonsense
nonsense.
What is the content?
What is the quality of your ideas?
How much time do you spend focusing on these ideas?
Which,
which by the way has nothing to do.
It's not like what you're saying is that women aren't as capable of doing that
job.
But what you're saying is there may not,
it's not about that.
It's about who's in front of you at the time and who do you want to put in that
position and,
and where are your,
you know,
what,
what are you going to care about at the end of the day,
you're going to care about the contribution that's being made.
There's this amazing interview that Ronda Rousey did recently in Australia cause
she's supposed to be fighting.
Um,
well she is fighting in a couple of weeks in Australia and it's the biggest UFC
event ever headlined by a woman.
Okay.
70,000 seats in Australia.
And this woman does this interview or does this question,
sorry,
this is a media scrum and she says,
um,
how do you feel we were having an issue here in Australia with,
uh,
equality of pay for women's football.
How do you feel about equality of pay in the UFC?
And this is why it's such a stupid question because she makes more money than
anyone in the sport.
She's the number one earner in the UFC.
And she goes,
look,
I get paid the most out of anyone in the UFC and I'm a woman and I don't get
paid that much because Dana and Lorenzo,
the owners of the company wanted to do something nice for the ladies.
She's like,
I get paid the most because I put the most asses in the seats and more people
want to come to see me because I'm the best,
you know.
And when she said that everybody cheered and they were Boone when this lady had
this question.
But her question is preposterous.
Yeah,
it's a ridiculous question because you're,
you're talking to the number one earner in his board who happens to have a
vagina.
Right.
You know,
it's,
it's the,
she got there through the quality of her work and the amount of eyes that she
attracts because of that work.
That's,
it's that simple.
It's that simple that what she's been able to do,
the,
the outlier status that she has been,
this beautiful woman that kicks people's asses had being unusual.
It generates a significant amount of money,
so much money that she makes more money than anybody else.
So this idea that like you're supposed to pay women the same amount that you pay
men.
Well,
well what if only half the people go to see the women?
Do you still have pay them the same amount?
Well,
that's a shitty business model because then you're not gonna make as much money.
Yeah.
It's,
that's a tough way.
I mean,
it's,
it's a tough way to look at it.
It's a tough concept to unpack for a lot of people.
I feel like,
I don't know why.
I mean they think that,
you know,
it's supposed to be one for you and one for me.
No,
it's a competition,
right.
When you get out into the marketplace.
Yeah,
the same.
The,
the,
I think the most,
the example that resonated best with me was the,
um,
uh,
the Jennifer Lawrence thing where,
where she did you read about that?
Where she was,
there's the huge,
uh,
she wrote a big open letter about how she didn't get paid as much as Bradley
Cooper did a during the American also movie and,
and,
and for a whole bunch of reasons.
Uh,
and,
okay.
That's fair.
I am.
Okay.
I want to hear,
I want to hear the argument right.
But the argument that I heard was,
was incomplete.
Right.
Um,
how about the number of lines?
Both of them spoke in the movie,
right?
How about the number of minutes both of them spent on screen in the movie?
Um,
how about the number of days she even went to work compared to the number of
days he went to work to be on set and to do filming.
Right.
And,
and so when you look at that quantitatively,
you go,
well,
why,
why wouldn't you be paid the same amount as him for for a fourth or fifth lead
role in that movie?
Right.
When you look at it quantitatively,
she actually got paid more per minute than he did.
Sure.
There you go.
And,
and,
and then so,
and then what you don't hear her talking about,
of course.
And I don't,
I don't like this argument either cause there's no,
again,
there's no reason that like they need to,
the other side needs to lose for one side to when it shouldn't be about that.
But of course then you look at like the,
the new movie that she's in where she's getting paid more than any of her male
costars and you don't talk about that.
Right.
And,
and so it's almost like this,
we,
we get angry and outraged about things when they're convenient to be angry and
outraged about.
And we don't,
we don't call it out on the bullshit when it's the double standard,
when it's on the other side of that curve.
Well I give her a pass because the whole world saw her asshole and it wasn't her
idea.
You know?
I mean,
I think she's probably emotionally wrecked because of that.
And there's also probably a lot of people in our ear telling her she got fucked
over and agents and managers and a lot of people
you could go out and you,
and you can,
you can talk about this,
this is the right time to talk about this.
Right.
And again,
that's that,
that's that smart people who have figured out how to manipulate the masses
emotions into,
into getting profit,
into getting eyeballs,
into getting ratings and to getting good things for that.
And I,
I'm always against that.
Well,
the argument is interesting.
You know,
the argument is very interesting.
Like who should get be getting paid what and why should you be getting paid
more?
But the reality is you're going to have a really hard time getting sympathetic
voices or sympathetic ears rather when you're making millions of dollars,
like,
oh,
I'm only making 2 million while he's making four or whatever the fuck it was
like,
boy,
cry me a river,
you're making millions of dollars and you want people to feel bad.
Like that's kind of ridiculous.
And if you look at it in terms of the number of,
like you said the number of hours that she was onscreen,
but who knows?
Who knows why she said that?
Who knows?
I mean she,
she actually,
she got shit on by this reporter or wants,
cause she was at some award show and she was drunk and he wrote something about
it and she had some response.
They know to,
you know why she did it and you know,
fuck this guy and like you're really worried about me because I got drunk at
award show,
like fuck off and it,
and she's right.
It gets 100% right.
And would she have gotten that grief if she was a man?
I say no.
If you know,
fucking fill in the blank.
If Brad Pitt had a couple of drinks at some award show and he was liquored up
and laugh and,
and being ridiculous,
he could say,
hey,
I was just fucked up at that award show and I had a good time,
but whoops,
what did I say?
And no one's going to say,
boy,
I'm really worried about Brad Pitt.
So no one's,
no one's saying that inequality doesn't exist.
It definitely exists.
And as long as we're having pragmatic conversations about it and we're staring
it in the face because it is an ugly issue,
it's a scary issue.
But as long as we're not taking teams and rattling palm POVs,
as long as we're not,
we're not just just,
just cutting off the lines and making boundaries.
As long as we're constantly having that conversation and we're not looking for
someone else to get hurt in the process of having that conversation,
then as long as we're still talking about it,
we're going to be making progress.
I think what you just said is so important,
as long as you don't want other people to get hurt.
Yeah.
That.
I think that's a really important point of it that you,
you don't want to hurt the other people.
What?
You don't want to hurt team dick in order to prop up team vagina.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't make me scared.
Don't make me scared to participate.
After that whole Donald Sterling thing with me,
I was,
I absolutely was scared for like months.
Like maybe I shouldn't tweet anymore.
But of course I came back to my senses and I thought that's ridiculous.
I shouldn't,
I shouldn't feel that way.
I shouldn't be pushing away from the table because some,
you know,
bad shit happened to me.
I that made me want to talk about things even more.
I mean this and then wanting to to make people learn that that's not the way you
get your way or that's not the way that you make a point is by bringing someone
else down.
Yeah.
Well I think it's also companies get scared and they get scared of backlash and
boycotts and they make executive decisions and those executive decisions are
oftentimes only made in those,
in that context and the large company form.
Like that's the only time.
Like if there's just a couple of people,
like you're saying you don't see it.
Yeah,
I don't see it.
Oh,
but I'm not going to see it.
I don't care if I said something like that and people got upset,
I would go,
oh,
I have to go.
Whatever.
I just let I do.
I'd say something else.
I'd say something even more outrageous.
I would keep it going.
I don't care because I'm not going to get,
if I get fired by the UFC,
a bug.
Oh well hey guys,
loved working for you.
Still support the company.
Great time.
But I'm doing five other things at the same time and one of the reasons why I do
that,
it's I do it.
It's calculated.
I don't like only having one job because I don't like worrying about losing that
job.
I don't want to worry about shit,
especially if I have to worry about something that would impede on my ability to
speak freely.
Right.
I'm not interested,
you know?
That's why I'm not interested in network gigs.
Those are not fun because you have to fucking watch everything you say.
They want to take over your social media account.
You know,
that's what happens when you get on a television show.
They want to be able to tweet for you.
They want your pee.
Like I was talking to Arsenio Hall recently and you know he had that Arsenio
Hall show.
Yep.
That came back and he can't get it onto his Facebook.
He couldn't use his Twitter like they owned it.
A lot of youtubers are,
are going through the same stuff right now too.
A lot of youtubers who are assigning TV deals are coming back and going,
this is,
this is not what I wanted for my brand in my audience.
Right,
exactly.
They're stealing your,
your people and then they tweet for you and they want you to tweet promotional
things and they want you to,
you know,
promote your show and live tweet your show and we'll,
we'll do it for use.
They're going to do it in your voice.
This is amazing what I did this,
but it's not even you.
You get someone else saying that,
you know,
and I'm very adamant about if you,
there's just automatic tweets that'll happen on my page.
Like if something gets uploaded to youtube,
but if you see an opinion and if there's an opinion or a joke,
even if at the joke fails,
that's coming from my little fat fingers.
That's it.
That's the only way I would do it.
And I,
I think that it's what I loved what I tweeted you too.
I think I asked about like your producer for the show and you're like,
dude,
it's me.
Like what?
Like you're talking to me right now.
You're not talking to some other person.
Well that you know means Jamie.
Jamie's over there.
You could talk to him.
But I just think that,
I just think we live in a strange time and it's very important during this
strange time to keep your sanity and to,
to keep your ability to express yourself.
Because like you said,
as soon as you are afraid of speaking your opinion,
if as long as,
as soon as you think about typing something that you really believe in and he'd
say,
you know what,
it's not worth the risk.
I would like to keep these ones and Zeros showing up in my bank account.
Let me just back off that.
Who are you then?
Right?
Because you're not,
you're not who you are.
You're a slave.
You're a slave to the system.
The cliched phrase,
right?
So at that point you're a slave to the system and look,
look down three or four generations down the line of that and what does it look
like that it's not a place that I want to live.
We're all just these like diluted down versions of each other that are identical
in the same and don't have opinions and voices like that's don't want to hear
that either.
They want to hear those tweets or read those tweets.
When you write something like that and they go,
yeah,
that is fucked up.
This chick just recorded him and then not just recorded but broadcast it to the
world,
sold it to whatever outlets or somebody did.
Everyone ended up saying what I said,
I was ahead of the,
I was way ahead of the curve.
I said it like,
like the day after it all happened.
Right.
And I was the first,
I was the first one through the breach and I got fucking slammed for it.
Right.
Yeah.
Everybody ended up ultimately having that opinion about it.
And,
and yet the end of the day,
like she,
you know,
she know then.
Then she got sued by,
um,
by his now ex wife because she was getting showered with gifts that were from
her estate and all sorts of,
and it's like,
yeah,
you gotta realize that it all,
this is hearsay by the way.
I don't know anything about the,
the facts,
but legit leads a good word,
allegedly.
You got to imagine that she,
uh,
that,
you know,
something was like,
like you got to imagine that she was like,
was trying to get some money from,
from instead of releasing those tapes that sterling was like fuck off.
Like,
like do whatever you want with the tapes,
right?
Yeah.
Like I can totally see how that happened.
Maybe not like maybe that's not how it went down,
but I could totally see that playing out like some episode of the entourage,
right.
Where it's like,
um,
where,
where you just don't know how the motives were not pure.
Yeah.
And episode the entourage,
but funny.
It's different.
Well,
I think what's going on with,
with her and him is she's getting,
look,
it's prostitution.
It's really clear and simple.
I mean there's,
she's not fucking that guy.
She thinks she's hot.
Like if you're having sex with someone,
you should probably be attracted to them or be getting something out of it.
But we love that.
We love the reality of the way there.
The life.
Real life is like become an episode of any reality TV show that you've seen and
people in for the same reason that realities do you get.
It's so successful.
People love.
It's why Donald Trump's campaign is so successful right now because it's a
living,
breathing incarnation of reality TV.
You're absolutely right.
100% and we love it and we support it and we vote and we say yes.
Just like we would vote for reality TV.
Well it makes it exciting all of a sudden instead of someone saying some can
shit that,
you know,
a team of speech writers where he's like,
I want to put up a wall to Mexico and put my name on it.
Like what the fuck?
You know,
he comes exciting and essentially his NBA team,
did we?
No.
Does he have one?
W would if we did,
but it's a,
he's,
it's a year away.
So right now it's just fun.
It's just fun,
silliness until it gets down to whatever fucking corporate criminals they're
actually going to put into the position of actually running the country.
So right now it is reality TV.
It's what it is,
is it's the most interesting game in town right now.
It's a sport that everybody has to watch for whatever fucking reason.
You at least have to know the score.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
they also ultimately comes back to the mainstream media.
They're the ones who are,
are technically leading the charge.
They're the ones who everybody has kind of queuing off of and everybody's being
being influenced by,
and that's also something that I'm constantly going to be at odds with.
I'm always gonna fight that.
Yeah.
And mainstream media itself is just a money making machine.
It's not like this idea that mainstream media news is actually their,
their sole purpose is to disseminate information,
to educate the masses and to keep you informed about all the happenings in the
world.
It gives shit that way.
It used to,
it used to be when it was broadcast,
when it was,
what is the utility?
It was essentially a utility.
Well,
it's still exist in the form of online journalism.
I mean,
what's going on now today when you see something like the Guardian printing that
Ed Snowden,
all the,
the,
the revelations.
When no one else wanted to touch it.
I mean,
he went to other people first and they said no.
So that's real journalism.
When,
when someone print something incredibly controversial but something they think
is important,
that's going to piss off the entire country.
Wiki leaks,
that's real journalism.
But it happens.
It happens so infrequently because they were so scared.
They were terrified.
They should be Edward Snowden's living in Russia and a fucking homeboy,
the Pale ghost with the fuck's his name,
Julian massage.
Julian Assange is holed up in a fucking embassy.
He can't leave.
He stuck in a house.
It's all madness.
I mean,
those two people are arguably two of the most important figures of the 21st
century when it comes to establishing what is the current state of the
government when it comes to surveillance,
when it comes to the spreading of actual information about what's going on in
the world,
where are we at?
Well,
those two guys are responsible for two gigantic leaps of revelation where
everybody's had to stay.
Take a step back,
especially Edward Snowden.
Everybody's had to take a step back.
No,
what the fuck is happening when I not a text message and my just texting Jamie
and calling them a big queen or am I,
am I going to get in trouble with people like what's going to happen?
Is someone going to read some of my joke texts to one of my friends,
take it out of context and get me fired for that.
But that's,
that's the world we live in today.
We live in a very weird time and in these weird times,
the idea that CNN is going to kick you the fucking real deal,
they're going to drop the real knowledge on Fox News.
They don't give a fuck about you.
They're just trying to sell commercials.
It's all they're doing and every time that you click on one of those click baity
articles,
every time you click on one of those sensational tweets and hit their page,
you're part of the problem.
You're the one positively reinforcing that business model.
In a way.
I think honestly that it's beautiful that they operate in this way because
they're seeling their own demise.
I really do believe that.
I believe Fox News and CNN and all these people are ultimately they're on a path
they can't get off and that path leads to being irrelevant.
It's going to happen as long as that burned though man.
Cause I know,
right,
right.
When social media came out,
when Twitter was invented and when Facebook was invented,
people were saying the same thing.
They're like,
is this the end of two media?
How long has it been around?
Really a couple of years.
In a couple of years we've seen some massive changes.
I mean really incredible and,
and some bad like what happened to you.
But I think that what that is is this new found ability,
this new found ability that people didn't earn and they just have and they
don't.
They're irresponsible with it.
They don't know what they're doing with it.
They also don't understand what communication would it,
what it really means to Bro.
And they don't,
they're not taking into account how other people going to perceive them.
Like,
here's a perfect example,
Justine sacco.
You know her story?
Yes.
Everyone knows her story.
If you don't know it.
She was a publicist,
she was about to get on a plane to go to Africa and she goes,
I'm going to Africa.
Hope I don't get aids.
Just kidding.
I'm white,
lol.
And she went to sleep,
woke up in Africa,
fired and the whole world hated her and she deleted her Twitter account.
And she still hasn't recovered.
I mean,
it doesn't,
you wish you worked for some game company now that just got in trouble.
What does it say it again?
Fan Duel.
She works for Fan Abdul and she got in trouble recently.
What happened?
She didn't get in trouble.
Her name's just come out because they've gotten in trouble and she's,
well there,
there are myths them as their publicist.
Oh,
how hilarious is that?
You know?
Yeah.
They're there amidst to,
it's Kinda,
it's Kinda like me whenever I come to another company.
Right.
It's like,
it's like I have to of course answer that question and people are talking about,
oh,
it's Xyz company hired Josh Holen again.
Right?
Yeah.
But what you said was nothing like what she said,
but what she said she had like fucking 10 followers.
She thought she was being funny.
Like she's probably on an Xanax or something like that.
She probably popped into the MBN joke,
whatever.
It's just shitty.
Joe.
We've all had shitty jokes.
You've had plenty in your life.
Career load.
I'm not a comedian and I have shitty jokes at the time.
And Twitter,
you know,
it doesn't matter if you,
it doesn't matter if you don't agree with what she said you shouldn't want.
What happened to her to have happened to her.
Yes,
exactly.
And people wanted it.
They made it so badly they were calling for,
they were putting her head on a,
on a pike and demanding it.
There was another girl,
I can't remember her name,
but she,
she took a picture in front of,
she was at like the Arlington cemetery or something.
She,
she was uh,
in front of a sign that said,
um,
I'm like,
no,
no shouting or some are quiet,
please quiet,
quiet,
please be respectful or some sign like that.
And so she took a picture of Frederick wish she was like pretending like she was
yelling.
Um,
and you know,
just cause that's what she thought was finally now,
now she put it on line and it went crazy cause because people were talking about
how she was disrespecting our troops and our soldiers and the last ones,
right.
And then of course,
so she goes out and talks about it.
She goes,
if you look at my page,
I,
that's just what I do.
Whenever I see a sign,
when I see a sign that says no smoking,
I put up a fake cigarette in my lips.
When I see a sign that says no soliciting,
I pretend like I was listening it.
Her shtick is she just does the opposite thing that signs say.
And when you,
when you understand that context,
you realize she's just being funny.
Why,
why would she lose her job over that?
But it's this odd,
she lose her job.
Uh,
I don't know.
Actually.
I don't know enough about it.
I shouldn't be talking out of my ass right now,
but whatever,
whatever it was,
there was,
outreach is a big thing.
There's a big thing and that's why I had,
I had a comment out.
Of course I defended her,
um,
and she was doing media and whatnot.
Of course,
it's so insane.
But again,
it's just the green light.
It's all it is.
It's just content in the gas and they just,
I found one,
we found a target called show.
Oh fire.
That's what it is.
When the Cecil,
the lion thing happened,
there was a New York Times article that a man from Zimbabwe road and it's a in
Zimbabwe,
we do not cry for Lyons.
And he talked about lions that have killed his family.
The guy lost his leg to a poisonous snake bite.
The guy who wrote the article,
I mean,
he's like his,
his take was like,
look,
Africa,
the wilds of Africa is not your friend is,
is,
it's fucking terrifying.
It's beautiful to behold,
but it is absolutely terrifying.
So this idea that you call this lion's Cecil and that we're all crying because
we'd lost Cecil Fuck's he soul,
you know,
I mean that's what he's saying.
All I did,
I mean all I did was retweet that article.
Yeah.
And I got so many fucking people that were angry with me.
What was the article?
It was the angle of the article and the article was in Zimbabwe.
Do not cry for lions.
That was the title of the article.
It was written by,
um,
I don't know if he was a student.
I forget what he,
but he's living in America,
but he's from Zimbabwe.
Right.
And um,
well we don't,
we don't,
we don't understand.
We are,
are,
we have no perspective outside of our bubble that we live in.
Exactly.
Well also,
I mean this guy is just giving his point of view as a person who was from
Zimbabwe.
You know,
I mean,
this is,
this is his,
all I did was retweet the article.
If so many fucking people are angry at me,
there was so mad at me,
I can't believe you're supporting this.
You know what that guy did?
Is it,
he's a piece of shit and a murderer.
And I like as if you just went and stepped on a kitten.
Yeah,
exactly.
Hitting kittens with baseball bats over the fence into your yard.
Right?
Like it's,
it's,
it's just the green one.
It's,
it's a,
it's an indoor,
you're right,
it's great.
It's,
it's this endorphin drip that we seek.
And when we get it through this feedback loop of what we get it through,
anger,
anger releases it,
and then we get it through the feedback loop of seeing someone else paying for
something that youth they didn't,
it didn't agree with or that you didn't like.
And I'm,
I'm sometimes too much of an optimist,
but I'm also,
uh,
I,
I tried to look at things objectively outside the context of culture and what we
expect of today.
And I look to the future and when I'm looking at is there is a trend and the
trend is from the moment that human beings invented language to the time they
started writing things down to the time they started distributing that written
word to the time they figured out how to broadcast and how to get ideas out
there through television and radio to the Internet.
What I'm seeing is the trend is a shorter distance between human beings.
There's a trend.
The trend is connectivity and I think ultimately we're dealing with this
adolescent period in this kind of activity where all these people that have
never thought about the idea of progress put projecting these words.
Like if you get a guy like Brian Williams on TV and he's bullshit and about
going to Iraq,
that's the guy that's responsible for his words.
Okay,
that's the guy that's a professional broadcaster.
He should know what he's saying when he gets on television,
he sees that red light.
He,
he's,
he's getting paid or do that.
He's getting paid.
He's,
he's prepared for it his entire fucking life.
Okay.
That's a guy who understands the,
the,
the re,
the repercussions of his words.
The average person has the same ability to reach human beings as Brian Williams.
When Justine Sacco wrote that tweet,
she probably reached as much people or as many people as Brian Williams did when
he lied about going to our,
or getting shot down in Iraq.
Right.
It's probably incredibly similar.
Yes.
And that's a new thing that is a really,
really,
really new thing.
I think as it gets closer and closer,
it's going to move from the written word.
It's going to move from type and video and it's going to be some sort of a brain
to brain interface.
And when that starts happening,
and I don't think we're far away from that,
I think we're a decade or two at most,
when that starts happening,
this is all going to be bullshit.
It's not going,
I'm gonna be able to read your thoughts and I'm not,
I'm not going to wonder whether or not you know your reacting because you were
beaten as a child or your,
you know,
your boyfriend dumped you.
I'm going to know and we're going to know each other in a really weird,
intense,
intimate way then I don't think we'd get possibly understand today.
When you talk to people that live during the fucking,
during the inquisition and you told them about Twitter when go to them and hand
them this device and see what they do.
So they'd shoot you for witchcraft.
Well,
they didn't have guns.
They'd fucking stab you or they'd fucking whatever.
But we're going to look at something like that.
Something in the future and probably the fairly fairly,
I don't mean,
I want to say no more than 20 years.
I think it's in our lifetime.
That's,
that might be ambitious.
Well maybe not.
When I learned,
I look at people like one of my idols is like Elon Musk when I looked like a
truly visionary person who also a really smart dude.
Just a genius and on every level when,
when a guy like him is talking about AI scaring him.
Yes.
And when he,
when he's going,
it scares me.
I'm going,
I should probably be scared to guys because,
and when you think about,
yeah.
With the way that we're already right now,
like a fusing computer chips in with brains and helping to restore language
centers.
Well,
what happens when that AI computer chip can directly interface with your brain
and learn about it and learn about its circuitry and understand it in a way
that,
and at a rate that we did,
it took us this many years to,
to learn and it's going to learn it overnight.
And then a second.
Um,
yeah,
that's a scary idea.
I did a podcast with Sam Harris recently in the last half hour of the podcast
was all about Ai.
It was all about a conference that he had want to,
and he had gone to this conference with,
uh,
like one idea about what AI was and left terrified and left saying,
well,
this is not just something to be fearful of.
This is something inevitable.
Yeah.
And Ilan Musk statement that we are summoning the demon was just horrific.
That's,
that's a terrifying thought.
Chilling.
That it came from the mouth of such a smart dude too.
It's going to happen.
I think we are,
I mean my,
my way of describing it and I've been talking about this for a long time that I
think we are some sort of an electronic cocoon where the electronic caterpillar
that's going to become the butterfly we were,
we are developing into something like when a,
when a caterpillar creates a cocoon,
it doesn't know what the fuck it's doing.
It's not reading manuals.
It didn't go to school for it.
It's not like it's not like,
you know,
meeting together with other caterpillar support groups and are you prepared for
your transition into butterfly them?
No,
they just fucking do it.
They don't even know why.
This is the next thing that I do now is I think this cocoon.
I think that's what we're doing.
I think that's what we're doing at our obsession with technology or obsession
with innovation.
I really firmly believe that we are fueling even through our obsession with
materialism,
because materialism ultimately you,
you always want the biggest,
best thing,
the newest,
latest,
greatest.
And the companies have to keep up.
So they're all competing.
You know,
nexus has to come up with a better phone because the iPhone six s is out and
then that,
you know,
fucking boom,
boom,
boom.
And it keeps going faster and faster and faster until you,
you're getting your Dick sucked by a robot man.
You know?
And then the,
that robot is a deciding that it wants to take over your house and turn into a
nuclear fusion center.
I mean,
who the fuck knows what a hundred years from now looks like or thousand years
from now it looks like.
But I think that what we're seeing with all this electronic outrage and all
these people communicating worth seeing this,
these initial blips of this new found ability to communicate.
Do you think that that's a new found awakening?
It's an important step in the process of what you're saying or unnecessary.
It's inevitable,
but I think that,
um,
I'm very optimistic about where that's going to lead.
I think the beauty is,
and if we all realize that we're all just human beings and that competition is
actually good because the real competition is with yourself to do your best and
you are inspired by other people who are doing their best.
You compare yourself to them and instead of shitting on them instead of trying
to put them down,
you look at them and get inspired or maybe not.
Maybe you say,
I,
I appreciate the amount of effort that person's done,
but I don't want to work 12 hours a day.
I don't think that's smart.
I would rather surf.
I think surfing's a way to go.
I mean,
I think I have 80 years on this planet if I'm lucky.
I want to enjoy them in the inn is richly fulfilling away as possible and you
should be able to do that.
Yes.
What have you,
um,
are you familiar with a guy named Chuck Fresco?
Yes.
Yeah,
he does the,
uh,
the Venus project and all about resource based economies.
He,
I mean,
he,
he simply,
um,
you know,
he talks about it like we have enough resources on the planet to sustain every
human being that we will have for a long time,
equally fairly,
and they could do whatever they want as long as we got rid of the dollar,
as long as we got rid of the need to,
to earn a dollar into a mass,
these dollars and to spend them and to enhance your life through them.
If we just,
if you take like the,
an inventory management system that like Walmart has or Amazon has and scale it
up to a global level and you inventory every blade of grass,
every tree,
every piece of wood,
every,
every raw material or material that we have,
and then you create a system that for distributing to that equally and freely so
that anybody can have anything at anytime that they want.
That's a fucking great utopia,
eh.
The problem with that is it removes incentive.
Like there's a reason why people work hard.
The one of the reasons why people work hard,
it's because they want to get ahead.
And that's the idea right?
You want to have a nice home,
you want to create a book,
you want to,
you know,
you want to put together a project that ultimately reaches a lot of people.
Like when you're creating a game that you use,
how many people do you think would make that game if there was no money involved
in it?
That's our incentive now,
but maybe be a different incentive surface cause you already see that in,
in,
in current day,
in current day capitalism.
You see like a teacher,
a teacher isn't doing what she does for the,
for the money,
you know,
um,
surgeons are arguably doing highly specialized.
Surgeons aren't doing it for the money they're doing it for.
Maybe they had a child afflicted by a disease or they or researchers who do all
this stuff,
right?
They don't live extravagant lives,
but they love to research and look to solve problems.
I think maybe,
maybe there are enough people in the planet who are passionate about doing
things or,
or want to do something for a ha or,
or could want to do something for a higher reason than just money.
There's always going to be some that do.
But what percentage of our population are surgeons that do things specifically
because they had a child afflicted by the disease.
It's incredibly minute.
What percentage of our population is teachers that just want to help children
and it's not that big.
It's small.
You know.
And I think most people are out there struggling cause they want Alexis,
most people are out there.
They want to move into the house,
down the block.
They want to and these are not wise choices and a lot of ways cause they're not
engineering their life in a way that's harmonious or that's really going to
prepare them for a long healthy,
happy life.
They're just rat wheel in it.
They're just hamster wheel and it just fucking spinning and,
and trying to collect shit until they die.
And I,
but I think ultimately that's like our transition from living as apes trying to
compete against the other apes in order to fuck and make babies.
And then you get eaten by a Jaguar to live in an apartment in Los Angeles in
2015 and finding out that you got fired because you made something on Twitter
that,
you know,
upset people.
I mean there's,
there's this,
there's a transition involved there and the,
the radical transition of our environment changing it when you juxtapose that
with our physical transition,
but we're not much fucking different than we were a thousand years ago.
No,
the world sure it's fuck is.
Yeah.
You'd be a fascinating guy to discuss like the Fermi paradox with,
I feel like,
cause you're,
you said you're optimistic,
so like wait,
is that the ultimate doom for humanity?
I don't think there's an ultimate doom.
I think humanity,
look,
if you went back to the neanderthal days and said,
listen,
you guys are fucked.
Let's just enjoy your time here.
It keep throwing those fucking spears of Willie Mamis.
But ultimately you ain't gonna make it.
What,
what would they do?
Would they carry on with it?
Keep going.
What would you went back to the ancient hominids that we're living in Africa
that had just climbed down from the trees and sort of experimenting with nude
food sources and trying to figure out tools.
Would you say,
hey look,
guys,
I know you're,
you're,
you're trying real hard to keep your family alive and you're trying to,
but your family's fucked,
right?
You people are fucking,
you know,
even figured out shoes.
He's still have thumbs in your feet.
You're not going to make it.
He's going to be some new thing that comes after you that's going to be awesome.
It's going to have a goatee is going to be talking on a microphone on a podcast
that's you.
You know,
you,
if you were standing in the savannas of Africa 300,000 years ago when our
ancient hominid ancestors first started traveling around and figuring out
hunting and all sorts of other things,
you would look like a goddamn alien.
If you walked out holding onto your phone and started taking pictures of them,
how much different would that be than a spaceship landing in Washington DC and
then coming out with a ray gun and,
and baking duplicates of people,
right?
It would be probably less ridiculous if the aliens did that.
Then you showing up in Africa a half a million years ago.
But I think we would react to it differently than Africa half million years ago
would have reacted to that may be.
Um,
but I think our future is like the alien that comes down and reproduces people
with a laser.
I mean I think our future is,
I think that's why the alien archetype exists.
I,
I'm very pessimistic when it comes to,
or very cynical when it comes to the idea of a alien invasion.
Oh yeah.
This,
the idea that we've been abducted or the people have come here from or beings
have come here from another planet.
It's more likely in my mind that that archetype exists.
Cause we were extrapolating,
we're going from looking at gorillas to looking at people to looking at,
well,
what are we going to become?
What we become this big headed thing with very little used for muscle and
tissue.
We're probably going to communicate telepathically.
We're not going to need mouths are vocal chords and we're,
we're probably not even gonna need sex.
Right?
Because we've got probably gonna reproduce through some sort of a genetic
replication process created by scientists.
That's probably our future.
It's probably going to be more efficient,
more healthy.
We're,
we're our,
our monkey bodies that need sex.
We need to come and we need to feed it with food and all that.
We're kind of prisoners to that and I think slowly but surely,
if you can prove that people can be more harmonious and more happy or more
healthy or whatever the fuck would be the benefit in evolving past that,
I think it's almost inevitable.
I think that's when you look at this idea of this big headed thing with a little
skinny body,
fuck man,
that's,
it's kind of obvious like this is where we're going.
We're becoming more and more slender.
We're more,
we look at us in comparison to all the other animals.
Like if you grab your dogs like for like grab his skin,
it's fucking tough.
It's like they could bite each other and they don't even get hurt that much.
Right?
If you got bit by a dog,
you're fucked man.
But dogs like two dogs would get mad at each other at a dog park Ra and they
bite each other and everybody's,
okay,
let's walk off.
Yeah,
you need to put a little fucking,
you know,
little rubbing alcohol and his little ouchie and he's fine.
And then two days later that doesn't even look like a whole anymore.
We'd be fucked.
And I think our,
our soft,
fleshy bodies,
we're reacting to the lack of need to be hard.
You don't,
you don't need fans anymore.
You don't need a tough hide.
What you need is a big brain and what you need is it technological
innovation in order to,
to catch up to this incredible electronic world that we've created.
But again,
only a small,
tiny fraction of our society will be a part of that evolution.
The vast majority are just going to be along for the ride for that.
So what does that mean for the I would they be along for the ride?
If,
if,
if I think those a tiny fraction can create that.
Yeah,
but just like how many people use cell phones?
How many people use the Internet?
It's not a tiny fraction.
It's the vast majority.
And I think ultimately that's what's going to happen to the entire species.
I think the vast majority are going to be privy to the incredible innovations of
tiny,
small,
few people like Elon Musk.
Those are the ones,
those innovators,
those geniuses.
I hope so man.
And I couldn't,
it couldn't come any sooner,
honestly.
Like we asteroid,
oh,
we need to,
we need to be thinking way bigger than,
than we are right now.
I mean,
you look at it,
she didn't even like climate change,
right?
It's,
it's a bigger issue than just the United States.
Um,
it's a,
it's a global issue and the sooner that we can get on board at global agenda,
but man,
did we get far removed from the way this conversation's too?
We did,
but we didn't because I think ultimately what we're talking about when we're
talking about this outrage says Twitter outrage.
I think ultimately what it really boils down to is a bunch of people that are
being unreasonable and they're communicating in this unreasonable way,
but they're just,
there's,
they're out there.
There's a lot of them.
Most people,
like what percentage of people do you think really commented on that and got
outraged?
What,
when it comes to the,
in the scheme of like the America or,
or the planet,
less than 1%.
It's way less.
May.
Less than,
less than one 10th of 1%.
Exactly.
Tiny amount.
So most people,
this is what I think we across every issue,
every communication,
just through that,
there's a general challenge.
It's hard to think critically.
Critical thinking is not an easy thing to do.
And I think that,
I think that for a lot of people,
like take for example,
uh,
when two galaxies collide together,
what,
how do you describe what it looks like?
Describe what happens if you,
if you live through that.
When you pose that question is no living through that.
No,
there's,
when I posed the question to some people,
that's,
that's usually the answer,
right?
They go,
they go,
oh,
two galaxies collide and it's just shit crashed into each other.
And planets exploding and sons eating other stars and black holes eating each
other.
And the reality though,
when you think about,
and when you,
when you judge the magnitude of the distances between those objects,
reality is statistically,
it's unlikely any two object would come,
would impact at all.
They'll come close and you're going to have some gravitational effects.
But the odds that any two objects actually collides is really,
really,
really small.
And so when I think that when,
when you know,
you,
you pose that question,
a lot of people that they imagine this apocalyptic scenario,
but it's just,
it's because they have a tough time,
um,
estimating things,
they have a tough time thinking outside of their bubble,
outside of their own consciousness and to like,
you know,
what could that be?
It's why.
It's why Google used to have the,
um,
that interview question,
that famous one,
like how many golf balls will fit in this would fit in this
school bus.
Right?
And a lot of people criticize that as like,
ah,
what a dumb question that has nothing to do anything.
And it's like,
well,
they want to know do you,
do you say a million,
a billion or 100,000?
Right?
They want to know what scale are you,
are you able to estimate the size of an object?
Because that gives,
that just gives like a real quick feedback as to like,
where are you on the critical thinking level?
Um,
so I think that when,
when you,
when you apply that to what we were talking about today,
I think that a lot of,
a lot of people have a tough time and myself included,
have a tough time estimating and uh,
and,
and oftentimes taking a step back from whatever their current daily issue is.
Whatever their current stresses,
whatever their current,
uh,
endorphin release they're seeking is whatever their current thought is.
And they have a tough time always keeping in perspective perspective.
The big,
the big key here,
keeping in perspective like what the rest of the universe is and the world is
and the other people even just next door to you are going through,
well there was an article that I tweeted today,
um,
from Yahoo,
from the UK,
evidence of the multiverse.
We might have just bumped into another universe.
Hmm.
What was the evidence
weigh herself because you know,
it's one of those things that you have to read like four or five times in
Georgia in order to like really figure out like,
wait,
what are you saying?
So you have to dies me with me.
Hear you
through those nights where you click like 14,
15 links deep Wikipedia and you get done in life,
like four hours have gone by and you're like,
fuck,
I'm fried.
I need to go to bed.
Right.
Oh.
Or I'll watch documentaries on hyper novas or something like that.
And you try to wrap your head around the idea of a star exploding and taking out
the entire solar system or many other solar systems nearby.
And the fact that this is happening millions of times a day,
all throughout the universe.
If there was a,
um,
a documentary that they had,
I don't remember it was science channel or what channel it was on,
but we're scientists at one point in time were concerned that there was a war
going on in space because they were recognizing these gamma bursts,
these incredible bursts of massive amounts of energy.
And they were happening at a,
in a repeated fashion all throughout the sky.
And they had to try to figure out what the fuck was going on.
Is there an alien war?
Like this is like,
you know,
what could this be any decades ago?
Sure.
And slowly but surely they started figuring out like,
oh my God,
these are exploding stars.
These are Novas and they happen all the time.
And if it happens close by,
that's a wrap civilization.
Yeah,
that's a wrap.
Oral,
Oxygen.
No more water.
No,
no,
no.
You're not going to need that.
It's all,
it's all gone.
And that is the reality of the cosmos all throughout the sky.
When we look up there,
look up at infinity somewhere out there where you,
you know,
in a,
in impossible distance away from us,
a stars exploding and that's what they do.
Jason Silva,
cool.
Astrophysicist guy.
He a Jason.
Yeah,
he does awesome youtube videos.
He,
he,
he takes this incredibly difficult science and communicates in a way that we
emotionally respond to and I love that.
And he had a,
he was just talking about,
like he said,
one line in one of his videos somewhere where he was like up there.
That's not an up there far away place.
You're in the middle of it.
You're in the middle of the universe right now.
Like in and even our galaxy,
right.
We have these paintings of what the Milky Way Galaxy looks like.
People,
a lot of times people don't even have ever have the thought.
They would never need to even think about this,
that we don't have a picture of what our galaxy looks like.
We have an artist rendition of what we think our galaxy looks like,
but the furthest craft we have is barely out of our own like sun belt.
It's a out of our own like gravitational pull from our own son.
So,
um,
again,
just we're not even looking at it from outside.
Not yet.
Yeah.
I photos of the,
it won't happen anytime inside of our lifetimes.
No,
unless we figured out how to bypass the speed of light.
But yeah,
man.
Yeah.
And even then,
we're talking about hundreds of millions of light years.
So even going at the speed of light,
it's going to take a hundred million years.
The most mind fucky statistic that I ever saw in one of these documentaries was
there were talking about the possibility of each ho they were talking about the
relative size of supermassive black holes,
and that every galaxy has a supermassive black hole that's one half of 1% of the
mass of the galaxy,
the large,
the galaxy,
the black hole.
And they're speculating that inside that black hole may be a whole nother
universe with completely different laws.
And that inside that universe may be other galaxies that have supermassive black
holes at their center.
And inside those supermassive black holes,
there are other universes.
So in our hundreds of billions of galaxies,
there may be hundreds of billions of individual universes inside of those.
And when you go inside of them,
there's hundreds of billions of more individual galaxies with hundreds of
billions of more individual universes inside of them.
And that is ultimately intensely fractal.
And it is truly infinite in that sense.
In which one of those are we in right now?
Yeah,
it's mind fucky.
But Cecil was a lie and he lived in Zimbabwe and he was loved.
Donald Sterling's a piece of shit.
Don't joke about aids if you're white.
Exactly.
Yeah,
we're,
we're our,
our lack of perspective is a alarming,
but fuck it make sense.
I mean,
we still have these goddamn monkey bodies and I think that's ultimately going to
be the big pole or the big appeal of transcending this physical embodiment that
we carry our consciousness in and then accepting this idea of a symbiotic
relationship with some sort of microchips and fucking fiber optic lines or
whatever the hell it's going to take form up.
I mean,
we're essentially symbiotically connected to technology or it already with
glasses,
you know,
we need these fucking things that we've created that cover over our eyes to see
better or with phones.
Man,
I left my house the other day.
I got a hundred yards from my door in and went shit.
My phone.
It was like I left my baby on the roof.
Like I had turned around like I was terrified.
I mean,
that's ridiculous.
I can't just go somewhere and a borrow someone's phone and call my wife and go,
Hey,
I left my phone at home.
I'll be home in a couple of hours.
Fuck that.
Well,
that's why when you say that over the timeline you've seen we're getting closer
and closer to the connections when more people are getting connected and we're
going to connect it with more people and closer.
I agree technologically,
but I feel like in the real physical world that we live in,
we're getting further apart and we look at,
we look at people's lives on social media like on Instagram and Facebook and you
know,
all the models were coming out right now with their posts about,
you know,
Instagram models posting about how,
how,
you know what you don't see the side of it.
You don't see right.
The,
the hundred shots that it took her to get that perfect photo and the argument
she got in with her sister over.
Take one more,
take one more,
take one more before she got that perfect one that year.
Then liking and you're then trying to compare your life to,
we are pushing like our real connections in real personal lives where at first
of all we're judging ourselves based by this impossible,
unattainable standard on social media that,
that,
you know,
if people,
someone takes a bad picture,
they don't upload it,
they believe that one and they take a better picture.
And I think a better one,
better one better one until that's the one that,
that it doesn't even look at hardly looks like them anymore.
And now we're expected to measure us looking at the mirror against that
perfectly lit,
perfectly critiqued,
careful image of what we think are our next best person is like.
And that Scott,
some really weird implications to evolution.
I'll give you one example real quick with Instagram is um,
I have a little sister and I'm,
I'm terrified of when every time she gets in another social media account.
Cause I'm like,
oh no.
Like,
like,
you know what,
where,
where is this going to lead?
When I think about,
um,
young kids,
let's say impressionable teenagers who are going through the most important
biological and neurological development phase of their,
of their,
what will be their adult life.
They're coming into their identity and they have access to this dopamine drip,
this endorphin drip in their brain that generations before never had that kind
of access to it.
When a girl can upload a photo on to Instagram and start refreshing the dozens
of your hot baby,
sexy baby,
nice smile,
pretty girl.
And,
and she does that during a time when she's otherwise dealing with a difficult
conflicting emotion inside of her and that's now her drug.
That's her escape from otherwise facing that reality and growing through it the
way generations before did.
I'm not saying it's necessarily bad or wrong,
maybe this is a better way to go through that stage of your life,
but maybe it's not.
Maybe that's
bad that you can so easily bypass all that hard shit you would have otherwise
had to have dealt with internally.
Right.
What is that doing to,
to evolution?
You know,
we don't know.
We won't know for a long time until we look back on it and go,
that was,
that was probably not great.
Or maybe we look back at it and go,
that's what led us to where we are,
but it's got to have some impact and that kind of stuff.
You know,
I deal with on a daily basis as I try to figure out like,
oh,
how do I want to bring my games on these platforms and all I want to buy games,
interact with people in these ways.
Yeah.
I mean we really don't know.
We're just guessing.
These children are Guinea pigs,
right?
They're growing up in this weird world,
I mean,
uh,
I grew up in a world where you could bullshit,
you could lie.
Nobody knew.
Just Google a little Ruth Zuni fucking 35 miles across.
Do don't worry about it.
Like now when people Google it and go,
you're an idiot.
It's 24,000 miles dummy.
You can hear the smart one now.
Cause he googled it.
I think,
um,
I have this other thought about these things and this progression and I think
that we look at the world,
we look at everything that's going on,
whether it's butterflies or elk or eagles or caterpillars.
And we look at it all and we say,
well,
that's nature,
but we look at ourselves and because we're conscious and because we can make
choices and because we can objective really look at the risks versus rewards of
each decision and debated amongst each other and seek advice from peers.
We don't think of it as natural.
We think of it as something that we can manipulate and something that we can
change and that we can alter.
But I think that human behavior might just be ultimately the most complex
version of the natural world that we know and that all of our behavior,
all this stuff that we're doing,
whether it's are rampant materialism,
our obsession with a tension and technology,
all this stuff is leading to what I said before that this electronic
caterpillar,
I think that what we are,
what we're doing right now is totally natural.
And this a obsession with checking your likes on your ass.
Pick to make sure that everybody thinks you're hot.
This is,
this is all just going to fuel your desire to get a better camera.
It's going to fuel your desire to,
uh,
get a new phone or to support the newest social media platform that's gonna
allow your ass to shake and a much more enticing way that's going to get you
even more likes and hearts and fucking thumbs ups and emojis.
I think it's natural.
I really do.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't know what we can do about it other than communicate our concerns about
the potential downfalls of this behavior and this kind of thing.
Confront the negative.
Don't,
don't shy away from it.
Confronted,
solve the negative problems that are coming with it as well.
Keep an open mind about it and,
and never stopped communicating because we do that.
We've,
we've lost that.
We've lost sight of what the goal of,
and that's what's a huge problem with that company firing you.
Cause they,
they impeded on your ability to communicate and you communicate it in a very
concise,
objective,
analytical way.
You looked at the problem,
he said,
look,
this guy,
he has every right to be an old bigot and the privacy of his own home,
like the fact that you got in trouble for that,
it's,
it shows the repercussions and the downfalls of this new time and when we
stopped communicating.
Yes.
And especially when also when you let in too many voices.
Like how about you and that guy sitting down,
you and that guy that wanted to fire you.
Right.
I would sit down and have a fucking conversation.
I mean not,
don't shut off my email.
Stupid.
Like what are you doing meet at Starbucks.
How about fuck you?
Yeah.
You know,
I mean wouldn't you have loved to have a few million bucks in the bank right
then?
Oh boy,
you just go shit,
suck my Dick Stupid.
Oh boy.
He just go online and just do a a youtube video.
Listen to with this dummy.
Just help me.
Well I did that day.
They were trying to dangle severance and stuff and tangle and pay.
Yeah.
I said fuck no to that,
you know,
I,
when that whole thing was unfolding,
um,
it,
it got,
it got like a lot because so a lot of media outlets you,
you,
um,
I I linked it to the opiate Anthony,
they,
they talked about it and they completely had my back obviously cause those guys
are super levelheaded people.
But,
but the um,
the,
the media shit storm that started to unfold,
CNN,
Fox News,
everybody,
every major outlet was reaching out to me,
trying to get me to come on their show.
And I was sitting at a crossroads.
I am a communications professional.
I knew that and I had seen what happened to Justine sacco before.
I think that happened for me.
Um,
and,
and I,
I was,
I was well aware of where this could go for me in my career and my personal
life.
So I realized that,
you know,
I need to take control of,
of the,
of the Pr Shit Storm.
I need to be the one who makes the right moves while the company makes all the
wrong moves and I need to get this back on track.
So they didn't,
you know,
part part of their terms.
They didn't want me to do any media appearances whatsoever.
They want,
they wanted us to go away.
Right.
Course cowards.
And so I,
I couldn't,
I couldn't take the blood money I have to do.
I had to make sure that how much that one right
costing you a lot.
Yeah.
Tens of tens of thousands of dollars for you.
Fuck them.
Yeah.
I hope it cost them even more.
They um,
you know how that guy keep his job.
The guy who fired you,
how did he keep his job?
The,
the,
the culture of that company was different too.
You got to it.
It would take a long time to unpack the,
the,
the complexities of how a publisher relationship works with a studio in our
industry.
And so they were at the studio level and they just wanted to make fucking games.
They're artists,
they're creators.
They just wanted to make cool shit and go to work and have fun doing it.
And then the,
the publisher was the one who had the business relationships.
They're the ones who had relationships with the NBA that they were afraid of,
but they were funding the studio's development.
They didn't own the studio,
but they funded it.
And so like when it comes down from the top where they go,
oh,
you know,
he can't work on the project anymore.
We're not going to,
we're not going to give you any more funding.
It's like,
I would love for someone from that company to,
to call the bluff because I don't think that would ever come that.
But um,
but they couldn't.
And I,
it's,
it's sucks that they got put in that position.
It's sucks that,
that no one there,
it could have the backbone.
I know how I would've handled it if I was running that company at the time.
What would you have done?
I would've,
I would've said,
I would've said I would've called the bluff of the,
of the publishing company.
And I would have said,
that's ridiculous.
Uh,
wait a day,
nothing is going to happen and we'll talk about it again tomorrow.
And then when nothing happened and when everything goes away and no business
deals were threatened,
we'd go now,
what was the big fucking deal?
Yeah,
It's finished making the game.
Let's not have a bunch of people mad at us because we,
we,
you know,
trampled all over someone's constitutional rights and let's,
let's,
you know,
let's implement his good ideas.
That was the other thing that they lost was all of these programs and
initiatives that I was building and that I was going to take charge of and run
through the Games,
lunch cycle and keeping all of the players engaged and all this stuff I had done
before I was going to do again for them on this new Ip,
this new thing that like,
that needed that work more than anything.
It didn't have anything to build off of.
It was starting from zero.
Um,
all that was gone.
Like,
they didn't have a person to come in that could carry those,
those,
you know,
carry that torch further and finish the job.
I'd started good.
Oh good.
That's their punishment for being pussies.
It's sucks at suck for everybody,
but you like your new job.
I do like my job better.
I get to,
I get to make and that I get to explain what your new job is.
People at home.
Well,
so,
um,
so anybody who knows video games,
I worked for a company now called Three d realms.
Huge company.
Well they used to be a huge company,
small company now,
but huge name.
Right?
Because they're the guys who made like Duke Nukem.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Commander Keen.
Like these are some of the most retro old school classics that,
that,
you know,
influenced an entire industry.
And is there less people were going in and out?
Oh,
absolutely.
Yeah.
They,
they,
for the last decade where they weren't really doing anything,
um,
it would just,
you know,
shrink,
shrink.
So now they're,
they,
they had a bunch of litigation that was happening as well that they were able to
finally put to rest and now the company is able to look to the future.
And so they brought me on to be like,
let's,
let's start,
let's build this thing back up and we're going to start with a new Ip.
And that new IP is called bombshell.
What does an IP intellectual property,
okay,
so internet protocol,
I'm like,
how's that a nerd now work IP,
intellectual property.
It's just,
it's a,
it's a franchise.
So bomb shells,
the new brand,
the new game,
creating a whole new slate of characters.
Um,
and it's,
uh,
it's,
it's what we want to,
to start that sort of come back for three realms.
The game,
I don't know you,
you said you played games,
shoot camera.
Um,
for a long time.
For many,
many years to a point where,
how to walk away.
I was always wasting way too much time playing.
Mostly quake.
Okay.
That was the big one.
I was playing quake online fucking eight,
eight,
10 hours a day sometimes.
Yeah.
But Duke Nukem I know that there was a new one that they worked on forever.
It got to be a forever.
Yeah.
But it got to be a joke.
People,
the online joke was,
you know,
it's going to come out right after Duke Nukem comes out or there was all these
jokes about when it would come out.
Yeah.
It did come out eventually did come out eventually.
And um,
and it's tough for anything that,
that goes for 12 years of highway 12 years.
Like yeah,
it was like something like 12 years.
How does that happen?
And explained that to me.
Well,
die wasn't here for that,
so I don't,
I don't know all the story,
but you're not responsible from what I know.
Yes.
From what I know is,
uh,
the game just went through a lot of iteration.
So every year the next big thing came out and the game was no longer the next
big thing.
So they had to add some more stuff to it to try to beat the next,
the thing that just came out and then something else came up.
And so this constant trying to,
you know,
striving for perfection and there was other problems and there was lots of
controversy.
You could read articles,
um,
for,
you know,
for days,
literally days where people are just investigating that whole evolution of that
franchise they using for the three d engine was the unreal engine.
It kept changing.
That was the thing like the engine,
the engine kept changing,
the technology kept changing,
the requirements kept changed,
everything kept changing.
Instead of just polishing something up,
sticking with what you had in getting it out the door,
you,
you can you compare that to the game where we're working on now,
like bombshell,
right?
Bombshells built on unreal engine three,
that's the last generation revenue your lunch and unreal engines on for now.
It's just,
it's,
it's unreal engine now.
Um,
and,
but,
but imagine if they,
if for bomb show we had an indefinitely kept upgrading the engine,
changing new technologies,
implementing new technologies and new workflows and new stacks and new things
breaking,
it would never end.
It would be a never ending building and polishing cycles.
So that was kind of what my perspective,
any of what Duke Nukem was stuck in for a long time.
So it was just a poor management yeah.
Project and,
and you know,
creatively you could,
you could debate whether it was also creatively like,
um,
you know,
almost like this,
this need for perfection,
you know,
like,
like no one,
no one pixel can be out of place,
that type of thing.
Um,
and people did,
they pointed fingers to that whole thing.
But at the end of the day,
what came out was Duke Nukem forever and,
and it wasn't,
um,
you know,
I don't think anything could sustain like a decade of hype and ever live up to
that expectation.
That good.
Was it a good game to people enjoy it?
No,
it was,
it was a pretty infamously like poor game.
It was like,
but again,
I don't think that it was the fault of the,
of the game or the developers.
I think it was maybe,
maybe to some extent,
but,
but I think more than anything,
it was failed by its own image.
It was like,
it was like this,
it was built up and gamers had like built this,
this expectation in their head about what it could be and then it just,
it wasn't,
you know,
you'd never had a chance of living up to that.
Um,
imagine rebooting a,
like a crazy old franchise and it just never living up to it.
Living up to what you would have expected from that.
Yeah,
kind of.
It's kind of impossible,
right?
I mean it's,
it's to have something go on for 12 years,
just like they just have to get it out to cut their losses.
Right?
Yeah.
So,
so that,
that,
you know,
happened finally.
It's,
it's,
it's in the past and now we're able to,
to focus on the future,
which is,
which is new Ip,
which is bombshell.
Did you,
you're,
so,
you're familiar with Duke Nukem enough,
you know,
where that character was like?
Sure.
Well,
back in the day,
in the 90s,
that kind of character works,
right,
because it's a super one dimensional character.
Arnold Schwarzenegger and Predator.
Exactly.
And just,
just the,
the,
the perfect stereotype of what that likes sports,
a nigger or Stallone character was from the 80s will reincarnate and in video
game form in the 90s.
Right.
Well,
um,
that kind of character doesn't really work.
Yeah.
There he is.
Super Brooding masculinity and it's just,
yeah,
so the belt buckle so that that character doesn't even,
that character today would have,
it would have trouble playing.
People come to expect more depth and complexity from,
I feel like from their characters,
certainly in movies and in,
in all the video games we play.
So things evolve.
So bombshell,
uh,
was a character,
she's not one of those,
but she was a character who actually originated in the Duke Nukem era.
Like back in the nineties.
She was concept it and conceived as a sidekick to Duke Nukem.
And so when she was originally conceived,
she was this kind of overly satirical version of the,
of the female sexy time check as well in the same way Duke was.
Right,
which may have played back then,
but it certainly wouldn't play it today in the culture that we have now with,
with feminism.
And with women in gaming and,
and,
and even beyond that,
just simply,
she wasn't a complex character.
She wasn't interested in character.
She wasn't propelling necessarily that storyline.
So we had to kind of go back to the drawing board with this version of
bombshell,
the one that we've been working on the last couple of years.
Oh,
she's bad ass.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's even the,
that's the old version of bombshell.
Oh,
what does she look like now?
So now she's,
she's much less bare.
Midriffs.
Right.
Much less skin.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Let's pull up,
up,
down,
down.
Right above the one you had open that one.
Yes.
That's the same one.
No,
no,
no.
The one where she's holding the revolver.
Yes.
Yeah.
So this is just there.
You don't see much.
But over here,
click on the two to the right one down that one.
Yes.
Oh no,
that's not it either.
Well,
close out of this.
Go to just go to bombshell.com because we actually bought this domain away from,
uh,
it used to be like psalms,
horn mogul had it.
No,
it's an ass.
Oh No.
Yeah.
So we,
we bought,
you have to pay for it.
I don't know.
It was before my time,
but,
but God got it away from that and now we've turned it into,
so that's the rub.
I'm sure.
So she's got this bionic arm and she is a character is defined more by who,
what she's been through and,
and,
and like way very multifaceted personalities and attributes,
not just traits,
not just physical appearance.
Do you have to run this past feminism in gaming?
No.
That it's okay.
No,
but what I need to ask for all Gamers,
right?
Is to look at this and go,
it's not,
it's not easy making a strong female character that can,
uh,
sustain that can appeal to both men and women.
Um,
tomb raider,
right?
So we get to draw from awesome inspirations like Lara Crop,
Sarah,
Connor,
even Ripley,
right?
Um,
and,
and we're able to look at like,
yeah,
this works.
But what makes that thing work?
It's not,
it's not,
the physical appearance is not what you look like.
It's,
it's who you
are and what you stand for.
So Shelly bombshell,
she got her nickname because she was like the foremost bomb disposal expert in
the GDF is actually lost her arm.
It is how she lost her arm.
And so now she her look,
she's real.
Oh,
was kind of disturbing me.
It dude.
She to us,
she is and,
and we want to see it in constantly and bring it to life dude.
Oh cause players,
um,
so um,
she was a part of the Duke Nukem franchise.
She was,
if you scroll down or you can click on the media link at the top,
you can see more screenshots that are a little bit closer.
There you go.
As Duke Nukem the only game that,
well there's Dika Katana.
Right.
That was another game that kind of went that way.
It was dragged on.
It was John Romero after he left it software.
It was a little,
yeah,
it was sort of typecast as well.
That was a fucking good game though.
Sure.
That's,
that came,
got fucked over.
That was a fun game.
Like the physics were cool.
It was like very much like quake one but with better graphics and weapons were
cool.
Yes.
Yeah.
And and,
and I've,
excuse me,
I'm not saying those games don't have a place they do.
Right.
And that's the thing like,
like we,
what we don't want to be doing to,
to creators to create a people to artists is making them kind of like kind of
like we didn't want to walk on egg shells with combat with talking about these
controversial issues today.
And I feel like we didn't,
we don't want our artist walking on eggshells worried about worried about well
what are people gonna think are they going to be,
I think it'd be down to our next for being sexist or misogynist or,
or fueling some,
some negative negative aspect of,
of pop culture.
Well she's got big tits so you're in trouble,
right?
Look at her like people are going to definitely say that you're doing something
wrong because she's hot.
I hope not so far.
No one has,
I mean I haven't seen it yet.
Wait till this fucking podcast goes live.
She,
she is hot and wait until you watch a trailer.
I don't know if you were able to,
she's got to fight.
Is that the boss?
One of the bosses?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Can you,
can you pull up videos cause yeah.
Fuck yeah,
you should.
You should pull it.
The Xero earth guardians on our youtube video.
Yeah.
We'll make sure you don't shut down our youtube videos because that's what
happens.
That's what they do is your intellectual property of whatever fucking complain
about us.
Oh No,
you don't say that.
No.
There's gotta be some company at the head of this though.
Absolutely.
It's our company.
Yeah,
but do you have the pole?
Can you really make this happen?
Absolutely.
You'll never.
All right.
Find a video.
Jamie.
bombshell.com if you scroll up,
it's the,
it's the top one at the here,
right?
A little bit down to that middle one.
All right,
here we go.
Yup.
Is Xero screen?
Yeah,
the packs one.
All right.
Hit that pitch and go full screen.
I also love our music.
We have an incredible composer.
[inaudible] name's Andrew whole shore.
Why is it freezing?
Okay.
Stop.
Pause.
Listen,
we can't watch it like this.
Pause it.
Let it,
let it load up.
Okay.
It is loaded.
I saw the buffer.
Yeah.
Something's wrong with your fucking shitty buffer on Youtube.
Try it from the beginning.
Jammer.
Okay.
These are the zeroth guardians today.
It's because you went full screen,
right?
Did you just leave like this?
This is fine.
I agree.
More
English isn't that convenient.
So she'll do the game.
Kind of be like breaking the fourth wall,
talking to the audience.
It's almost like she knows this is like a,
you're looking at it.
It's third person.
It's top down.
Yeah,
it's an isometric gave.
So,
so this is,
it's amazing when you can just now seeing how far along,
even from when this video was recorded,
how much better the game is.
But these are the Xero earth guardians.
One of the boss fights here playing with two sticks on your controller.
Um,
so you're,
you're running around with a left one and you're handling with the right thumb
stick and then you're just,
you're,
you're shooting,
you're using different abilities,
different,
uh,
you know,
she's got her mighty punch.
She's got eight different weapons that she can finish.
The [inaudible] textbox type controller.
Yeah.
Playstation,
Xbox one and playstation four.
It's going to be like the,
the controllers that you come to expect on PC,
which is releasing later this month is the keyboard and mouse configuration as
well.
So that's where always be top down like this.
No.
So sometimes we pull it down into third person just got jacked.
It was made by,
it was made on the unreal engine.
So we're able to build it in super high fidelity and you can bring down the
camera to be like if a third person game almost in the game was actually kind of
designed to be a first person or third person shooter.
Yeah.
First person is my favorite because it feels like you're actually there.
You know,
you're running through these three d worlds.
Top down is like you're either watching,
well if you love quake,
and if you love first person shooters,
we actually have a build engine prequel to bombshell that's going to come out,
uh,
after this game that,
um,
that takes place in the first person and it looks very retro style.
Like,
oh,
so when is this game out?
So this game comes out November 26th.
A PC.
Yeah.
Oh,
this is where they merged together.
It's a stage three of the boss.
He's coming out first.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
They merge.
Yeah.
They literally merged together now.
So now they're one giant boss.
Oh,
this seems like a hard game to play.
Yeah,
it's got,
have you ever played dark souls?
No.
It's got times where it's Kinda got dark souls difficulty.
It's not an easy game,
but it's also very accessible game and easy to pick up and play.
Well,
it looks awesome.
This is very,
this is the kill sequence.
And this,
to me,
you're kind of defines it about her personality.
It defines our personality.
Yeah.
Sets the tone for who she is
for the folks.
This at home,
I mean listening to this,
which is the vast majority of the people.
This is not that fun.
So uh,
for them go to bombshell.com and you can watch these videos and check it out.
But very cool graphics.
It looks like a fun game to play and if you really into games,
there's probably something you check out.
The thing about games that I like is that the amount of fucking entertainment
you get from a really good video game and how much is a good video game cost
these days.
Typically they're 59 bucks,
60 bucks.
Think about how many hours of entertainment you can get from what,
especially if you turn it into a first person shooter where you go online and
play multiplayer,
right?
Oh my gosh.
Hundreds of hours people are putting into this thing and this game is not going
to be that much.
This came to be like 39 bucks.
It's,
it's a single player on the game.
Doesn't have,
oh really?
Yeah.
Single player.
Only game.
But we want to make like co op this game would be so fun for that.
But like,
yeah,
like you talk about even the full price games,
like the call of duty will be 60 bucks.
Right?
Well that game with,
with how many hours you get to put into it,
you compare it to like a two hour movie that you see for 12 bucks or 14 bucks
down at the AMC.
Right?
Right.
And you're getting so much bigger bang for your entertainment dollar buying a
video game than you would in a movie.
And so a lot of times when people are worried about our games getting too
pricey,
you know,
with mobile games being so cheap and so affordable that they are,
um,
you know,
with how much entertainment you're getting out of it.
It's crazy.
I don't think these artists are getting paid enough,
honestly.
Well,
the amount of money that you guys make don't video games is bigger than any
movie now,
right?
Oh yeah.
Yes.
It's,
it's surpassed I think 2012 or 13 that's crazy.
When it surpassed.
Holly wouldn't.
Yeah.
When did it surpass porn?
I don't know that it's started way earlier.
Corn does it make that much money anymore?
They say the way porn makes big money these days,
and this is kind of a sneaky thing,
is um,
uh,
hotels,
that's where people buy porn.
Interesting.
That's where people most of the time by well if you're a business guy,
you could expense it.
The trip,
you can expense it on your trip and 1999 for a movie.
But if you watch,
yeah,
if you play,
if you play bombshell and if you walk away with a different image,
jump into your head.
Then just that blonde babe scantily clad tits and ass.
Then we've done something.
We left an impression on you that that tells you that that what defines a bomb
show,
it defines a bad ass chick is,
is more of her context in her life and what she's doing and how she's combating
that adversity than it is what she looks.
Are you guys preparing for feminists blowback feminism and gaming blowback?
No.
I mean I think about it a little bit more of myself just because of the way I
think.
And what I've been through,
but that's not what the team had.
Inner interceptors.
The studio in Denmark making that game intercept,
no one there is thinking that they're just thinking.
We have this idea for an incredible,
incredible chick and incredible villain to hate Jadus Haskell.
He's the villain.
You didn't see him in that trailer,
but he is the lead a antagonist.
He's voiced by the voice of Duke Nukem,
John Saint John,
so he's also part of the three d realms.
Family's still there.
Just looking at making incredible characters with a fun story.
One's saying
this story is serious,
like you saw it.
She rides,
she rides a shield and punches him in the face to do the extra.
Well,
she throws some grenades under the shield,
blows them up and go find,
which is like that classic over the top almost be action movie type stuff.
Right,
but that's,
that's the game that we're making.
We don't want it to be too serious.
Right.
We want it to still be on the fund side a series.
Now,
speaking of technology and technology of the future,
are you guys going to start doing things like oculus rift?
You can just going to start producing games for,
for something that's like completely immersive like that we could man,
we don't want to say no to anything.
We couldn't say yes now.
He had done nothing to announce on your show unfortunately.
But it's,
it's the technology is amazing.
Have you tried it?
Have you worn those?
I've only worn while I have one to two versions of worn the original version,
which is very pixelated,
which was amazing because it gave me this like,
Whoa,
this idea of like,
I see where this is going.
And then more recently,
um,
my friend Louis from unbox therapy was in here and he showed me one that's a
cell phone.
You slide it in Samsung gear galaxy.
Yeah,
Samsung phone and you put it on,
but it's still not the real deal.
The real deal is the one that hooks up to a computer and,
but I saw that video where you get to look around.
It's completely three dimensional.
The guy playing the piano.
Have you seen that one?
Yeah,
it's mind blowing.
I've worn both the,
the valve has their vibe and then you have,
um,
you have the oculus rifts.
Sony has the,
uh,
has,
there's that,
what's the best one?
Uh,
they're,
they're all,
they're all bleeding edge.
They're all like,
you know,
to me they're all like at the same level.
They all have their different things.
One has more refresh rate.
One is high resolution,
one has the hand tracking so you can move your hands and stuff.
Like they're all,
they're all just,
it's such a new technology.
They're all making great strides and [inaudible] but no matter what,
when you're playing on the,
it's,
the experience is so hard to describe.
I'm going to do it injustice right now,
but it's like you really are in a different world.
I played a simulation where I was standing in this,
um,
uh,
this,
this halt.
We were like a,
like a jail cell,
like a jail hall and there's this t rex,
you hear it walking and it comes around the corner and it starts walking towards
you and is roaring.
It's super high.
Fidelity and you can look around,
you can move,
you can move around.
And when he started walking at me,
I had this like visceral natural instinct to duck down and then it detected that
I had ducked it down because it can have the motion tracking like the we remotes
do.
And uh,
and so he leaned down and like looked at me and roared and my face and then he
walked over me and I realized that I've never had that reaction from a normal
game where I've like had to physically move in my space.
But that made me have this like response in my,
I felt my heart rate going up.
That was so much more immersive and you can,
you have to experience it.
If you ever have a chance to go to like a trade show,
like Penny Arcade Expo,
Pax South or Pax East,
um,
go to these trade shows and like wait in line,
it's worth it.
Try it out because it's such an incredible experience.
Well,
I know John Carmack is involved with some oculus rift stuff cause we were
tweeting back and forth and I've been a [inaudible] studios way back when
before,
um,
quake
three was released.
I got to play like an early version of it with Tim Willits and all those guys
online or on a land rather.
It was really fucking cool.
But they're doing some crazy oculus rift shit and I just can only imagine what
that's going to be like.
The first oculus game we make over.
I'll bring you in.
I want you to see it.
I want you to tell us what you,
what you think.
Well the first person shooter and Oculus rift with probably if you can get some
sort of an omnidirectional treadmill that feels realistic.
They have those too.
I've seen it's tough.
It's like a workout.
It's really hard to be is great because you know,
one of the things about dance dance revolution,
um,
that game that's like really popular in arcades.
One of the cool side effects is a lot of people lost weight,
like a shit load of weight because they were gamers.
But they got really into playing this one game.
This game requires you to jump around and bounce around and they were burning
off all these fucking crazy calories.
And there's,
I think there's a whole website dedicated to dance,
dance revolution,
a weight loss.
Like it's showing all these people that have lost like fucking 60 70 80 pounds
just playing this silly game.
Is this fun?
Yeah,
and they're having fun doing it.
Now think about a first person shooter like unreal style,
right?
And you're running around these corridors.
You've got an oculus rift headset on Omni Omnidirectional treadmill,
which means you can go left right back,
forth 45 degree angles up and down fuck band.
And then you use these.
A lot of these treadmills,
they operate on you pushing them,
right?
Because they don't move like a a treadmill.
We have to keep up with it.
Right?
It's your footprints are actually forcing it to move.
So there's a little bit of resistance to it.
The one that I had,
the one that I saw,
I didn't get to try it though,
is they had this thing,
this almost sock thing you put on instead of a shoe,
it's like a boot that's super soft material and then rather than the thing being
attract that you have to move and have all that resistance because that was
harder to move.
It was this really slick surface.
So you're still bound in but you just glide your feet over it.
Oh whoa.
That's cool.
You like Polish it up like a,
almost like a,
like a bowling alley.
You would.
And then so you're almost like walking in place in gliding and because you still
have that hardest holding up,
you don't slip and fall.
And that was kind of interesting too.
That is kind of interesting.
I would think one would be better for fitness.
Absolutely.
But the resistance probably get some,
a really good workouts in with an omnidirectional treadmill with resistance.
I mean if you're,
if you're like,
I know there's one that they're working on that I had heard is fucking
terrifying.
It's based on Ridley Scott Alien.
The,
the,
the first alien movie.
The game.
Yeah.
And if you seen it,
I've seen the clips.
Yeah,
I've heard it's fucking horrifying.
Where people were worried that people are literally going to get heart attacks.
Yes.
Because you're,
and you have to duck and he,
and you see it,
you actually see it walking around and it's trying to find you and you
physically have to duck and move your body down so that it can't see you in the
gate.
And when it finds you,
it roars at you.
And you watched the activity as the fine brothers.
It's the fine brothers Youtube channel where they have these,
um,
they,
and he's like teens react videos,
they'll put a teenager's in chairs,
they'll film them reacting to these things.
It's so fucking funny to watch them do a climbing.
They're climbing at their eyes,
trying to get the thing off because it was terrifying that,
well isn't that this and this,
like sort of a glimpse of what's going to happen when they figured out how to
make some sort of,
not just the goggles that you put on,
like like what they're doing with oculus rift,
but some sort of a neural interface where they bring you into this world.
Would you ever want to leave that world?
That's the question,
right?
I mean,
is that what we're going tricks maybe.
when we're talking about artificial life,
maybe that's how artificial I was going to coopt us think it.
Well look man,
we got this thing.
You know,
you don't need to live like this baby.
You know?
I mean,
how many people are out there just can't get people to touch them.
They're so sad.
So depressed.
Why would you do that when you can be Robin Hood,
right?
You can literally,
okay.
This is the people were watching a video of the people wearing the oculus rift
and a
turn it up,
Jamie Lee,
they,
oh my God,
this is amazing.
Oh,
first of all,
it moves like
a really high level 3d shooter with high resolution,
but it's total oculus rift.
Oh my God.
It's running.
Running at you.
Is that mean it got her?
Yeah.
Oh that's hilarious.
Cause I'm still convinced that this is all happening.
And then when it eats them,
it happens in front of them.
They can,
they can see them say complete down and see their intestines getting ripped out.
Yeah.
Terrific.
She's like,
dammit,
I just got jacked.
Whoa.
So when,
when that little face is on the corners,
that mean.
Got Ya.
Yeah.
There was a little bit buggy to that.
They were playing like a glitchy building and whatnot.
We're seeing the future.
Right?
I mean if you go back to pong and you look at what you've got now with bombshell
and you look at this and go,
what the fuck is that?
I mean,
Pong was what,
80 not 70 war.
Yeah,
long time ago.
I don't even remember.
I don't know.
I don't remember what year it was.
What year do you think pawn ones tell you?
Yes.
Jamie sixties yeah.
No,
really.
I guess 72 [inaudible] 70 1972 okay.
So think of that thing is 72 and now think of what's going to be like 40 years
from now.
How cool and how quick we got here.
Yeah,
that's the thing at 40 years sounds like a long time.
43 years,
ain't shit.
No.
Well,
especially if you extrapolate,
you know,
you look at like what's going on today?
It's exponential.
It's not just 40 years from now.
It's like 40 years,
40 days.
Let's,
let's go.
Just back to 2005 right to just,
just 10 years,
2005 the video games were,
they were,
they were completely different.
They were still in large part.
Sprite driven.
Sprites are a bit,
well,
I'm not going to get into the technical right.
Yeah.
I'm not going to get into the technical jargon,
but it does.
I mean,
I,
it's,
it's not truly three d like the effects are,
are fakes today.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
It's just like a bunch of two d objects put together and at any way.
Um,
but this,
this virtual reality was something that always had been talked about a long time
ago.
It was always like the thing,
like one day we're going to have virtual reality.
I mean it was,
it was a big plot line in movies and like the 1980s,
but the technology wasn't there,
but now the technology has finally caught up to it.
And again,
this is just the beginning.
It's going to get crazier than this.
Right.
I would hope so.
I would assume so much teacher.
Um,
what,
what I want to know is how is it going to change?
Like what Netflix has changed the whaling Hollywood and,
and how TV shows are made.
Like I want to know what those,
I can't wait to find out when an experience through it.
Um,
the effect that's gonna have on game.
We'll do,
what about movies?
There was a,
um,
there was a movie that a,
they did a trailer for that was an Oculus rift and a,
it was pretty innocuous.
Yeah.
It was completely three dimensional.
Like you could get inside the movie,
you could move around and watch things happen from different places inside the
movie.
That's incredible.
Yeah,
and this is where I think what they did,
I saw it online and uh,
they were just sort of demonstrating it.
It might just be like a proof of concept sort of a thing.
Sure.
But they were doing it in real time and this person will like moving around,
watching all this shit happen.
I mean,
we're going to go,
like if you go to a movie theater,
right?
You're sitting in a theater,
it's a big hole,
big giant place number.
Sitting down and eating popcorn,
watching this flat screen in front of you where everything takes place.
What if instead of that you enter into a warehouse and that warehouse is the
film you strap on these goggles and they have an environment with wind and heat
and all sorts of different three dimensional environmental effects that can
allow you to like different terrain.
Like maybe the,
the,
the terrain is somehow under pliable or movable or liquid.
They can change what the effects of it are.
And you could,
you could walk around in the Shire.
I mean you could be in the fucking hobbit land climbing the hill to where Bilbo
Baggins houses opening the door,
looking at him and he's telling you to come on inside.
This isn't,
this isn't unrealistic,
right?
Oh,
it's already here.
There's the one proof of concept video.
Maybe Jamie can find it where it's with the oculus rift,
they created three.
They created a third person shooter.
So it's,
it's a real life third person game where the guy has a wide angle camera mounted
in a backpack on his back that is back here.
So it looks down and it can see himself standing there and he's wearing these,
these,
these three glasses and it's doing the head tracking in real time.
There's maybe like an 80 millisecond delay.
So it almost imperceivable.
So he's seeing his own is literally living an out of body experience through
accurate and he's walking around like he's the third person Avatar to the world.
Wow.
Right.
We know some games allow you to go from third person to first person until I
switched back and forth.
That's going to be a like to look at your own hands in the game on the trigger
and I could see your hand pulling and that's what the vibe was two and an
oculus.
I think oculus came out with a peripheral as well.
Now where you hold,
you hold these little things in your hands and now that the head tracking device
can track or the cameras can track where your hands are with in relation to your
eyes so you can hold a gun up and see the gun that you're holding.
Yeah,
totally makes sense.
Why wouldn't you?
You know,
I mean if if you're game,
I mean that would be so much more immersive.
If you had a game that required you to shoot it monsters with a shotgun and you
had a fake shotgun but it is heavy like a metal shotgun and had a real cocking
mechanism and you could really see the shells you jacked,
you had to put new shells in.
Maybe like maybe you have shells in your pocket and that's how you reload.
Like maybe have like a bucket of shells,
but fuck it could be awesome.
You've seen Hollow Lens,
right?
No Hollow Lens is,
is in a lot of ways,
even better.
I've,
I've seen it,
oh,
where they had aliens and breaking through the walls of your home.
So you,
it's not yet god goes,
that's like a lens.
And so you still see your space,
but it's like as soon as you put them on,
you could look at that wall and now suddenly an alien can break through the wall
and it make,
it actually makes it look like your wall is tearing apart and aliens climbing
through it.
And then you're shooting at the alien in your own house,
at your own wall.
So it's bringing video games into your world instead of putting,
transplanting you into another world.
How the Lens is bringing that game experience into wherever your space is.
I forgot the name of it.
Yeah,
but I do remember that now.
And then there was the other one.
Um,
what was it?
Magic leap.
Yeah.
That's the other one where they're showing three D holograms.
Like have a little elephant dancing in your hand.
If that's ballon,
that magic leap demonstrations have come out recently.
I'll try it.
I'll find it for you real quick.
Yeah,
like a,
like a real demonstration.
Well they had one where it was fascinating.
It was just a little girl sitting on her bed watching a four inch high ballerina
spinning around in a bed.
Like it was a real ballerina.
Like it was fucking Tinkerbell.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And again,
what does that do to a generation of mind blowing new inspiration and
imagination that no other generation like ours had?
Yeah.
And where does it lead?
Because obviously they're going to take it to the next place.
As they become more educated and they go to school and they learn how to create
this kind of content and they learned how to evolve it and make it better and
make the technology better and fucking Christ.
Man,
we're in for some weird shit.
That's a good time to be alive.
It's amazing.
It's the best time to be alive ever.
And we have so much shit to complain about though.
Yeah.
We've always had shit to complain about.
Oh,
this is real.
It says that this was shot through the magic leap.
Right.
Okay.
Play it like two weeks ago.
Whoa,
whoa.
October 14th,
2015 no special effects
or compositing were used
and it's not all glitzy.
It's not like having trouble.
It's so smooth with every motion of the,
so that's underneath the table.
We're looking at this robot thing.
That's super cool.
Oh whoa.
This girl sitting at a desk and she's a excellent posture by the way,
as she's sitting there,
there is a fucking solar system floating over her desk,
but it looks real.
It looks realistic.
At least there's trails.
That's what they're trying to show is the focus.
It reacts to the depth of field of the real world.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Wow.
I says so as you get close to it,
if you look at it like you could focus on earth like there's,
it's our source system,
there's our son and it's all the planets are the right size and the proper order
and just imagine that the applications for this,
imagine when a science teacher can put this in a classroom and let you like walk
around a universe or a galaxy and interact with the objects in,
in like your actual space.
When I'm confused as what's the projection method?
How are they doing that?
It's a lens that they're wearing.
I correct me if I'm wrong,
Jamie.
I don't know this one.
I don't think Erin's not letting anyone know.
I think as afraid now because it's super high concept and they're not sharing
because that girl's playing it all cool.
She wasn't even looking at the solar system right next to her.
If just kind of horse shit.
If that was like hollow lens is technology.
They were,
they had the camera looking at through the filter that would be projecting that
into the world.
Yeah,
so you still have to wear a device I would assume.
I would assume.
Okay.
I would assume,
yeah,
because there was one image that they had a where it was a floating whale.
They were on the beach and they were looking up and above the beach like where
the sand is.
There was a whale that was floating in the sky.
I could only imagine that that would be the case if you were wearing some
goggles or something like that.
How we'll see.
How are you going to project something in the air and have it look completely
three dimensional and solid and yeah,
look at this.
This is the one,
oh yeah,
I did see this clip.
Oh my God.
But here's the thing,
weren't so,
weren't all of them in the youtube clip I saw all the people in the room were
reacting to.
Exactly.
But here you're seeing a bunch of kids in a gymnasium that are watching this
whale fly through the air,
but the kids don't have anything on their eyes.
So we can see.
Right.
See this is kind of bullshit.
Like w they'll tell us eventually.
Yeah.
But obviously this is some stunt stuff they're working on right now.
When I saw the amazing,
I assumed that they were just reacting to the,
they were just acting because they had said,
oh,
now there's a whale jumping out and just react to so that it makes the viral
video on you.
That's what I thought happened.
But it might be fine.
That's weird.
You know,
it's weird to be alive now and see all this stuff happening.
And just,
uh,
just the speculation of what it's going to be like in a decade.
Well,
you're a little bit older than me.
Um,
W W W I mean you've got to eight,
you're 48 so you got to experience,
how old are you?
28.
So you've a lot older than you.
You got,
you got to experience what time was like as an adult before all this stuff.
So even when was your memo?
Yeah,
well,
I remember no internet right now.
A 1994.
I got my first computer was a,
as an old Mack back when max only had tam those boxes.
You know,
I had one of those and uh,
I remember thinking,
what,
how crazy is this internet thing?
You've got mail,
you know,
go on AOL and look around.
It's been completely fascinating to watch that evolve and watch a change.
And a lot of it happened while I was,
um,
while I was on news radio.
Um,
the guys that I worked with,
a lot of the writers were like heavily into video games and those guys got me
addicted to quake.
It was quick too.
At the time because they had developed a local area network.
They had a installed a land in their office and they had spent a shitload of
time,
they supposed to be writing.
They would,
they would play games to like two o'clock in the morning and then start writing.
But it was so crazy.
I could,
I had never seen anything like it.
And that's how I became like massively addicted but also addicted to the
Internet.
And that's when I started going online and finding out about websites and
reading things and realizing you get your news online.
And I was like,
this is amazing.
You could read the news and they're like,
you'd get the news in real time.
Then I was thinking,
well well you don't have to wait until the morning for the paper to come out.
You just wait for the website to refresh and then it got smaller and it's kept
getting smaller and you have in your pocket at any moment you can get notified
when news happened.
Yeah,
that's gotta be see you.
I think you,
you and,
and even me and a lot of ways,
cause I remember a time before that too,
I was younger,
but I remember when the Internet was really getting into our house.
Um,
so I feel like we were like in a great,
a great generation for perspective.
And not to go back to all that stuff again,
but it's like the next generation,
even even,
even like my,
my younger sister's generation,
like they didn't have all that perspective necessarily.
And now I have little toddlers and nephews who are growing up with,
with,
you know,
iPads and they're there.
They're doing stuff sitting on the couch after school and their iPad.
And so I'm just worried like,
and what do you think,
do you think you were,
you and I are in like the good,
the best generation for perspective,
or do you think that it's better to be a generation,
a generation now or a generation before you and I?
Um,
well I think if you want to compare the two,
there's no way they're going to understand what it was like to not have the
internet.
They're not going understand it,
right?
It's going to be a concept.
It's like us understanding what it was like before written language.
Right?
We're never going to get it.
We can,
we can pretend all we like.
We're never going to really know what that's like.
But I think the leap
between written language and with no written language,
written language took so much longer to have an impact than what we're
experiencing in,
in just a couple of decades and a couple of decades.
The world has changed radically and it's happened right in front of our eyes.
Yeah,
and I think that human beings have a really difficult time recognizing change
while it's taking place right in front of them.
Right.
I think it just seems normal to us,
but I think when,
when history looks back at this era,
they're going to say,
this is the craziest moment in time.
This was when it all began.
This was the birth of the machine.
This was when it came alive.
When information became viral for the first time,
like literally viral,
like became almost a living organism and spread and there was hiccups and there
was Justine sacco and Josh Olin and there was all sorts of weird shit that
happened along the way and viral videos and fucking that.
What does that fucking guy from Korea,
Gangnam style is also,
there's all the strange things have happened,
you know,
strange things.
Hamster dance has been a lot of weird stuff that's happened because of the
Internet,
but ultimately it's,
it's,
it's more good than bad.
Oh yeah.
Way more good.
I think people were more informed,
more edge and I think they're kinder.
I really do.
I think he'd,
despite all these cuts that get crazy overstuff I think there's more good stuff
coming from people online.
It's,
it's also the communities that you foster.
Like the,
the people that I'm in contact with that connect to me through this podcast or
through my other stuff.
There's super positive.
It's so much more kind.
I mean you can find pockets of Douche bags they found form these little
communities and they just shit in each other's mouths all day.
You're going to find that with any sports,
you're going to find that with the video games,
with any witness,
you're going to have like minded communities and some of them are going to be
toxic.
But for the most part,
what I encounter and the people that I interact with online,
incredibly positive.
Even criticisms like the criticisms that I've experienced online,
for the most part,
the vast majority of them are polite,
vast majority.
You know,
I think that's rare.
I think also people are learning how to use social media and the Internet and
this new found ability.
They're learning how to do it.
And some people do it wrong.
I mean there's some people that have like essentially attack blogs.
You go to their blog,
it's just them shitting on one person or shitting on another person.
And why are they doing that?
Well,
they're doing that because they can,
you know,
cause it's the first time they've ever had a voice in their whole life and
they're gonna use it to displace,
you know,
some of the anger and hate that they have in their own life.
And they just throw it out there in the world.
And this,
these are all like hiccups and growing pains.
And I think it's amazing.
I really,
really do.
That's why,
that's why I do what I do.
That's why I liked it.
I like to still be talking to as many people as I can and changing and
influencing in a positive way,
hopefully as many lives as I,
because
just like the university,
you know,
I'm a part of it.
I'm in the middle of it and I want to,
I want to be a part of it and I want you to be a part of it.
That's why I love Comedians,
tuner respect comedians because they talk,
they talk about these kinds of social issues with such,
you know,
just on a just absolutely brazenness and they don't care.
Most people don't care what other people think about it.
And they make,
they make you laugh at the same time that they make you really think and be
thoughtful about it.
So I really respect what you do and,
and,
you know,
kind of paving the way for that because you,
you were doing that in an era before there was social media so,
well,
it was easier before there was social media.
You will,
you didn't get attacked for it.
It was limited to one room at a time.
Right?
You got attacked in that room,
you know,
but I think people had less of a,
they had less of this,
uh,
entitlement to outrage that people have now.
Right.
And I think that there has been some attacks on comedians that have gone sort of
the way that,
you know,
you see these attacks on people for whatever reason,
social media,
whether it's the lion killer guy or Justine sock,
or you who's going to be these targets that exist.
And they have occasionally gotten after comedians.
And for the most part,
comedians have vehemently and aggressively like supported and,
and defended themselves.
And one another stat.
Yeah.
And defendant one another.
It's a super important thing.
Like Daniel Tosh had an incident that,
you know,
there was a few comedians that actually turned on him and they were ostracized
by the community.
You know,
the people will never respect them more.
Forget that they,
for Social Media Brownie points,
they tried to pretend that what he did with some outrageous thing.
Okay.
By cracking jokes.
So it happens everywhere.
Cause that was the one,
the one thing that I wish would have,
if I could have changed anything about what happened with,
with me,
it would have been that I would loved for more of my peers to come out and been
like this is wrong.
I would love for more people to have had,
you know,
the,
the gonads to come out and say fuck that.
He didn't do anything wrong publicly.
They all came to be privately man causing.
Right.
But as you would expect friends to do.
But I would love for people to have been like,
you know what,
that's not okay.
And I,
cause I see that all the time in the comic community where that's how you fight
that.
That's how you get back against that and that's how you make sure that that shit
doesn't,
you know,
research and take over.
But we have to because without that the art form is shit.
I mean it really doesn't even exist.
The,
the,
the art form of standup comedy depends upon freedom because you're going to say
things that are offensive,
you know that you don't even mean because the offensive things will be funny,
you know,
and you've got to know when you meet him or when you don't meet him.
Like I went through this whole bit in my last special where I was explaining
like this is a Tracy Morgan bit that he got in trouble for,
cause he said that if his son was gay would stab him.
And then I'm like,
well he also said he would eat a mile of shit to get to Beyonce,
his ass.
Do you understand?
He said both of those things and the same set.
Like,
like we got to like look at what he's doing.
He's saying things that are outrageous that are not real.
He's not in court given an affidavit.
He's making a joke because he knows that some parents are shitheads when their
sons come out to them.
Right.
And that's the joke that he was making and I understand that.
And you think that's what he was doing?
No,
I think he was pretending that he would stab his son if he was gay because it's
outrageous.
I don't think he was saying like simple as that,
but yeah,
I don't think it was like a social stand.
Like we was taking a stand on social issues and mocking those parents that would
do that.
No,
I think he's pretending that he would do that.
But the last funny,
but it's protected.
But the last thing that he was doing and suggesting that's okay.
Yes,
exactly.
That's the important,
you know,
I mean people,
people have to look at what standup comedy is the same way they look at movies.
If you watch Goodfellas,
okay.
Nobody really got shot when they made that movie.
It was,
it was fake.
it was entertainment.
And if you listen to rap music,
same thing.
Okay.
They're not really shooting cops.
So what,
what,
what people,
what people think is,
is they argue that that bye bye fetishizing that by pretending that,
that we're somehow changing society and culture and,
and I completely reject that theory,
right?
And in video games we get that a lot with violence.
In video games,
there was a lot,
a lot of lawsuits actually went to the supreme court in California over
California versus the Ema.
And um,
thankfully video games one,
it was like a seven to two vote,
but the,
the,
what they were arguing is that violent video games can lead to these mass
shootings can lead to violence in your life,
lead to aggression despite not a single study supporting any of that evidence.
And I come to realize that video games as an industry,
we're just,
we're just younger as an,
as a,
as an as an art form,
where younger we're,
we're a very immature industry,
just like movies,
just like music m and Marilyn Manson went through the same scrutiny back when
they were having violent and vulgar,
let rap lyrics,
right?
They went for them.
Ozzy Osborne,
you know,
people were blaming them for kids killing people.
And every time we come to realize,
you know,
it's probably not real.
It's probably not the case.
And no matter what someone writes in a manifesto or what someone,
you know,
might,
some study person might think,
you know,
and at some university,
um,
there's nothing that suggests that.
And if anything,
there's data that suggests that,
you know,
these things as mediums or releases,
they lowered regression,
they,
um,
they make people happier and better people overall.
Yeah.
The release,
you know,
that there's this idea that watching something violent and watching something
sexual and watching these things that are horrific,
they release this anxiety and the least release the desire to actually do those
things.
Yeah.
And that you can somehow,
or another by,
you know,
by viewing those,
alleviate those issues in your own mind.
I used to work on call of duty.
And so we of course that that game like that has a close interaction with the,
with the armed services,
with,
with our,
our,
our militaries.
And,
uh,
and,
and every time that I met with them,
they would tell me stories about things like,
you know,
so vets would talk about how they deal with like PTSD.
They deal with adjusting to society by playing call of duty or,
or people on deployment in,
in like fob.
He's like,
you know,
boots in the sand would talk about going to get,
going in and playing these things.
Cause they would have little,
uh,
almost like Internet cafes.
They'd have little tent set up where they would go in and play these,
play the Games on,
on workstations and,
um,
and we actually would send some times x boxes out to them and,
and,
and um,
you know,
help them get through that stuff.
Uh,
and,
and again,
to them it was like that was their way of,
of keeping us a sense of sanity and normalcy to their,
their otherwise,
how the hell they had to go through.
And that,
you know,
those stories just,
they always ring home to me and I realized that,
um,
no matter how much,
but again,
it's just perspective.
It's like,
I,
it,
it still tears me down to think that we're still debating these things.
We're still debating whether finally video games and this and that,
and here's why the debate is bullshit.
Would it affect you if you went and saw a violent video game or a violent movie?
Would you go out and commit violence because of it?
No.
You're a grown adult.
So are,
what are we doing with video games?
We raising children with them.
No,
you're raising your fucking kid.
Okay.
And if your kid grows up to be a suicide bomber or a mass murderer or rapist,
you can't blame movies,
man.
It's not the movie's fault.
There were way more influential factors in that kid's life that led him to where
he was then the macula.
Exactly.
And usually whatever adjuncts that they have is,
you know,
they're,
they're seeking some sort of relief through those video games.
Right.
And if they have fucked up thoughts inside their head,
it's not Quintin Tarantino didn't put them in there.
Ozzy Osborne didn't put them in there,
you know,
call of duty didn't put them in there.
It just didn't,
it's not,
it's not the case.
They can live vicariously through those horrible things and not want to commit
crimes.
And that's,
and you know,
the argument could be made for that sexually to,
you know,
there's a lot of people that believe that porn,
uh,
even crazy porn,
alleviates people's desires and need to do fucked up things sexually or yet or
to do the thing that they watched in the,
in the porn.
Exactly.
Um,
and that's a good thing.
That's not making best desensitizing them.
That's not that.
Again,
that all comes from a place that I think just lack of understanding and almost
it comes to replace a close mindedness here.
It's that confirmation bias.
You have a theory and so you will look at the world through the stained glass
lenses of that theory.
Yeah.
Instead of looking at it objectively and understanding the data and what the
data's telling you and you're always going to have examples where you can point
the finger at that person and blame whatever and influences from the media,
whether it's music or games or films or anything for for their,
their behavior and their actions.
But you,
you got to have to look at all the factors in their life and what percentage of
the pie is the video game,
right?
It even a sliver.
I mean is it even a percent or 2% what about the 98% of them getting sexually
abused or beaten up or bullied or the fact mom drank like a
fish when they were in the womb?
Who the fuck knows that it makes what makes it broken person?
The idea that a person can be perfectly normal and then sit down and play call
of duty and want to go fucking shoot up a mall.
That's crazy talk and you as an adult producing a product that is supposed to be
it.
At the very least your parents are supposed to approve your use of it.
Right.
The eye.
But most of it is like Keith kids that are,
you know,
in their teens or older,
those are they,
they're formed their own personalities already.
You're not getting your personality from playing bombshell and even still,
we still have rating systems just like the movies have the EPA,
we still have the SRB.
We're still properly rating them and making sure that parents have to sign off
if they're going to buy the thing with the kid that to be there in the store,
you have to have a guard.
You know,
we still have all those same systems just in case.
Right.
Because it's still good to be better safe than,
sorry.
I agree,
but not to the degree that you're removing an entire John Mra of game or John or
of entertainment because of it being too safe and people should be allowed to
vote with their pocket book.
You know you should be able to vote with your wallet,
vote with.
If you think that something's offensive and you think grand theft auto it,
it legitimizes robbery and violence and I don't want to be a part of that.
So this is what you do.
You just don't buy it.
It's real simple and that let the open market decide and the idea that you were
going to fucking nanny state the whole world,
that it's nonsense.
It's nonsense.
And I think video games have been the latest victim or the latest in our culture
of something that Tipper Gore tried to do with rap music.
And I mean it's been done forever.
It's been done forever.
They've always tried to find a scapegoat for why people are fucked up.
But people are fucked up cause people are fucked up.
Deal with it,
deal with it,
face it face you don't understand it.
But that's okay.
We,
we,
we have,
we have more work to do to figure it out.
Don't just go to the easy thing,
the easy explanation that that makes you feel more comfortable at night.
Yeah.
We're not talking about John Carpenter.
What does that movie he did where the people read the book in the mouth of
madness.
They read the book and they went fucking crazy for reading the book.
Now there's a giant number of people play call of duty and never shoot anybody.
Okay?
You got to take them into account.
You can't just say,
well this guy played call of duty and then he went on shut.
What else did he do?
Did that Guy p?
Well when he pees it made them go out and shoot no more pigs.
Yeah,
no more ping.
Did he drink milk?
Well,
fucking milk kills milks out there killing babies.
That's nonsense.
I can't,
it's like,
it's like everything causes cancer.
Everything causes cancer these days.
Well,
everything causes death because we all die.
That's right.
So everything you do,
you get online that's causing death or fluffing.
We worked out a lot of shit today,
Josh.
I didn't to do.
I feel good about this process.
Thanks for letting me talk to you about it.
Uh,
my pleasure brother.
My pleasure and good luck with your game.
Good luck with bombshell.
Thank you.
And,
uh,
and,
everything else you do,
man.
I really appreciate it was a lot of fun.
Cheers,
brother.
Um,
j d underscore,
what does it,
what does that stand for?
It's funny.
[inaudible] there's a story.
I'll come in next time and tell you about it.
Okay.
Next time.
J D 2020
on Twitter,
Josh Hall and Ladies and Gentlemen.
All right.
See You fuckers next week.